une interview première voire très près
premier disque que tu as acheté au mieux
disque the piper at the gates of dawn du
queensland nord est et puis damien
sépare et non je suis un fou vous aimait
ses ambiances comme ça très petit tu
sais mon premier disque premier film que
tu as vu times le prochain film que j'ai
vu c'est mon jeune âge j'ai pleuré tout
marqué pour toujours
condition que j'ai souvent ils ont
blanche neige blanche neige le premier
fleurs premiers flirts 12 ont réuni une
vieille de 16 euros or copine de ma
soeur ma soeur en retard donc moi
produite en situations passage en caisse
qui appelle première phase est celle
dont je crois que c'est notre année
c'est très surprenant puisqu'en plus
pouvait pas expliquer ça à mes copains
de classe qui voulait s'acheter que de
40 bars au supermarché
c'était ses salles electrabel
marginalisée au bouc ou pour au moins
trois ou quatre premières idoles
première idole
vienne avant de rentrer tard dit je
crois que c'est françoise en fait
première idole c'est ça et les 10 de
près ce n'est que ma mère écoutait
america aide quand même jamais san remo
première cuite première cuite 15 ans
d'angleterre pour aller travailler dans
les hôtels est vraiment la mort de très
près la tête dans la cuvette des
chiottes toute la nuit à la bière je me
suis dit que je n'aurais plus jamais
dernière fois qu'il a fait la loi qui
fait 12 ans et demi at elle avait 13 ans
et demi à c'était la totale
tout a commencé par tous oui bah oui oui
et les garçons disons un garçon de 10
ans un copain de classe qui venaient
jouer à la maison
après les corps et c'est pas ce qui
s'est passé dans les têtes on s'est
déshabillé à une résistance qu'il
courait je me suis mis sur lui en le
truc absolument désespérant rien ne se
passe
mais gardent donc on s'est rhabillé on a
recours on la continue à jouer ensemble
en a jamais reparlé celle là oui oui ça
décolle de trelawny la dent c'est pas un
mec me reconnais comme il se reconnaîtra
premier succès premier succès disco
maintenant à mettre 1er juillet au
panama oui disent qu'on a tamponné
succès professionnel
prenez succès professionnel mon premier
disque quand même sympa marché au niveau
ventes s'étaient c'était génial de
pouvoir le voir en vitrine à rennes ni
thomas n'a pas beaucoup marché non
milliers d'éleveurs mille exemples de
l'art si paris à rennes et une à
regarder toute la journée comme ça
c'était très déçu on fait trop senti je
ne mets plus je pensais tout premier
million premier million
souvenir que j'affectionne
particulièrement c'était en 85 avec
tombés pour la france la question qui
correspondait par la france
ça changeait est carrément la ville est
à la fête
j'ai acheté une chaîne stéréo ce que
j'avais
cup encore c'était carrément les
intéressantes au niveau du matos l'ifi
geste une chaîne
et ces cités où c'était extraordinaire
ne pouvait avoir un peu d'argent devant
soi parce qu'on habitait dans un taudis
en
j'en avais vraiment va crever la dalle
mais c'est vrai que c'est pas les deux
d'origine c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est
pas des souvenirs malo premier cancer
premier concert
les transmusicales à rennes 20 minutes
le hockey pendant 20 minutes avec
certains musiciens d'art qui cède et des
copains qui peut faire les choeurs
c'était bien mon souvenir sa première
échec professionnel
je sais vernis j'ai pas de ce que vous
pensez pas vraiment d être vraiment des
échiquiers
je ne voterai sur le coup non ça va pour
maintenance et plus les échecs le
personnel que chaque personnel personnel
22 ans
c'est ce qui m'a
les premiers millions de nos francs
trois jours trois ans là ça commence à
venir c
sa balle au freinage est pas tout
puisque je viens d'acheter un
appartement pour une mère donc il faut
le vendre quelques disques
une première télé les premières ténue
fr3 rennes une réalisation
brillantissime et un fou rire qu'a duré
qu elle doit une table à son sens parce
que l'hystérie pendant trois nuits et la
dernière volonté ça sera quoi ma
dernière volonté
être assumée
perso
façon convaincante face une grande fête
un julien cabon soir on va faire
l'interview première fois à travers
est ce que tu es prêt à l'est
tout
audition pas prendre aux éditions
spéciales cbs avec un produit je dirais
non finie c'était des musiques de moi
c'était les tout premiers textes de mots
c'était dingue c'est ça non c'est bien
avant sagement et et c'est pour ça que
je dis que c'était un produit pas fini
il y avait même quelques tests de moi
qui étais pas très bon air tout ça j
arrete pas ensuite et donc normalement
le type qui s'appelle jean les clients
j'ai revu plusieurs fois et quand on rit
de 108 ans apparu le nom il est même le
fils de souplesse a mis 120 ans à lézat
et s'opposer en prime ce qu'ils m'ont
rappelé pour la reine après en me disant
de revenir sur retourner une deuxième
fois
je pense qu'à l'époque le rider aurait
été de ne faire chanter mais des
chansons écrites par d'autres positions
réfléchissent pense qu'il avait raison à
l'époque mais pour moi dans une question
qui après ses essais avec bob choqué que
ça vraiment marché voyez vous ce qu'est
un fabrice aujourd'hui rtl
et le troisième c'est plus était
vraiment les trois les zorra
mousquetaires devenue une amie de tes
parents qui qui connaissait c'était une
cousine de ma
mr dray nos cousines pour moi vocale qui
était à sur le sol alors
ge
mon père travaillait l'unesco se
rencontrer à mettre c'est que j'ai un
frère directeur artistique qu'est ce que
tu écris toujours les chansons et oui
nous avons été tellement vexé comme un
pou d'avoir été refusée pacy ps que je
n'étais dit plus jamais judiciaire s est
terminé il faudra venir me chercher
enfin la gtc et j'avais bien du mal à
sortir de cette promesse que je m'étais
fait et puis et puis non je suis donc
aller auditionner mais je me suis dit là
évidemment de mon alibi c'est que
c'était un cousin dans le sun été tué
par balles jeudi roger pas alors qu'en
vérité mais qui ne connaissent pas ce
très bon état et il avait rien à [ __ ]
de moi bon donc il m'a fait attendre
comme n'importe quel directeur à 6
cycles aurait fait attendre c'est à dire
plusieurs jours je suis allée moment ils
tiennent l'attendait en bas dans un café
etienne avait déjà puis avait déjà
sociaux ont annoncé tard il allait
acheter dans les librairies acheter de
les laver lettre qui devait redevenir
les lettres dit il y avait toute
l'énergie
ils avaient tous en il ya la situation
contrôlant byron et 6e étages byron dans
la pièce des des réunions un petit piano
droit face au mur j'ai joué la chanson
était le plus fier et 14 ans appelé
russell russie mise pour une première
audition est 14e et 4 x 6 minutes ça
faisait quand on était vachement fier de
ça c'était un chantage
jeudi l'âge taper sur ce piano j'étais
en sueur tout il était derrière moi
détroit 2 il se retournait en sorte que
j'étais tellement angoissé et choqués
qui ne s'est pas rien mais alors la
les bras m'en sont tombés là tu serais
chez jean pierre foucault et socke et
qui rentreraient bon alors le premier
disque à leur premier disque c'est à
l'assuré à la suite de cette audition
on a un peu continuer de décrire et
c'était un cavalerie socke est allé voir
un jeune arrangeur qu'elle fait très peu
de choses à ce moment là je crois qu'il
est très très bonne journée et qui
s'appelle encore petit
demandé d'en faire les arrangements que
je dis ça je m'en suis hors et touche
toujours de ce premier disney c'est vrai
qu'il est sorti au début de mai 68 c'est
le dr mais oui c'est le dernier qui a
été fabriqué après le mot cinétique
c'est fou et laurent et moi évidemment
pour les gentils seuil barry iv gt dans
les couloirs chez pathé et écouter la
radio pour savoir s'il allait passer oui
surtout je traînais dans les couloirs de
ce pacte est bon ça quand ça se passe
est foutue quelques bandes mais 68 ans
j'avais oui je l'avais vécu avant par
étienne interposés avant même que sa vie
n'a de l'irlande oui oui oui mais lui
même
j'allais chez lui avec des réunions dans
son dans son appartement et y habiter un
appart pardon à anthony hlm avec sa
maman mais sa femme est alors il
montrait un humain son fils d'ailleurs
que d'un grand boubou maintenant il y en
aurait dû ardres il montrer comment il
fallait faire pipi sur le pot parce que
l'humain est passé à côté 20e il disait
ça l'onu massaloux là il s'asseyait sur
le pot pour montrer comment il fallait
faire une
non non ils deviennent c'était le gaucho
mais union g8 et les fumées des boyards
lviv et de la vodka dans des petits
verres et toi vous étiez pas
spécialement gauchistes quand même nom
annonce alors une bonne humeur était
gaulliste ne peut hâter gaulle et sert
essayer même de me mettre dans ces 20
quitte en voyant défiler du sur les
champs elysées défilé de soutien j'ai
accompagné et je suis cassée par une
oui je ne te dire pourquoi je suis
partie par une rue adjacente demandé
d'avoir ce que les champs elysées me
semblait très long à monter et que ça
partait de très loin de la plaza
concorde mais en plus parce que j'ai
entendu des slogans ce jour là
des seconds raciste et d'estivants
assistant vers cohn bendit et tout ça
c'est si cela semble grave
alors je viens je veux pas qu'à à ce
point j'ai bien que j'ai toujours été
toute mon enfance entre la maison claire
et puis quand j'ai changé un communiqué
l'organisme il a alors j'ai pris une
rude
à 10 ans je me suis cassé et j'ai région
à la fin mais c'est vrai que cette image
un peu hippie que tu as eue dans les
rues début des 70 c'est plus venu de r
en fait que notre show évidemment un
taux facial mans hippie envoi du tout du
tout mais quand tu te retrouves et que
le pan de son viol est en train de faire
claude messant saint martin non non ça
c'est pas non c'était ceux ci en effet
d'accord ça ce n'est pas ton truc non
plus sur ce jeu mobile est un peu comme
chez nrj rodage il est paraît il je ne
voulais pas je le fasse mais y en a un
qui était super la danse est bon
parce que je suis quand même posé la
question ce clan j'ai lu spectacles à
londres j'ai trouvé ça vachement bien
ouais vous avez envie de le faire à ce
moment là ouais et l'ingénieur je me
souviens prendre un taxi d'ebola parce
que c'est qu'on n'est plus mais trop
près à la xi et pommeau pareil pour
l'aréna à paris et jeu 18 10 à vos mots
je vous écoute le spectacle et qui vont
bien là et on édifie le citron est le
bienvenu dans ta première tournée c'est
insensé aussi se dire que tu t'es
retrouvé des côtes avait dit moi je
viens de prendre mais d'abord pour qu'il
fasse un peu de sel et tu t'es retrouvé
avec adamo c'est ça paul louka et
parisienne exemple à toi ça te chante
ekwalla par exemple elle chante
c'était c'était la meilleure place qui
soit chanté trois chansons je rentrais
sur jivaro ensuite je faisais ivanovic
je sortais soit 15,7 et à ce voyage
était déjà connue parce que salut les
copains auraient déjà commencé à traquer
un barde était de la fif s'est
émerveillé tiennent aussi d'ailleurs
parce que lui pensait que c'était plus
de sites les intellos nouvel obs
victoire d'étape couverture enfin pas
encore convertir mais tu étais déjà dans
sa chute est la seule énervé vraiment
n'importe quoi qui étaient achetés en
comptant c'est parce qu'il est prévu
mais je crois qu'il est hors jeu
rencontrait première une justement cslc
c'est avec france dans les souks de
marrakech on a laissé sa place à la
mamounia
ouais ça t'embête et passe à 2 mètres
comme ça ne gênait pas non ça m'a gêné
enfin
ça me gênait un peu quand même c'est
parce qu'à l'époque avait un truc
complètement idiot c'est qu'on était
encore dans le vieux schémas de pensée
que quand on était un chanteur pour les
filles il fallait pas se montrer avec
affirme d'ailleurs que la cacher
français ont beaucoup gâché jour me suis
pas toujours très bien rendu le regrette
sa maman parce qu'il ne s'agit pas d'y
aller une photo dans france dimanche
qu'elles avaient un bandeau sur les yeux
et marquer il la cache
non c'est vrai elle en a souffert elle
parce qu'elle était pas au mieux de sa
carrière à l'époque souffrir est ce que
ton premier chagrin c'était quoi ton
premier gros chagrin d'amour c'est quand
elle est partie j'ai très mal vécu en
plus parce que je le faisais qui théorie
non non non j'ai pas de pluie pas bien
vécu dit ware envie je me suis même un
peu con plus dans ce chagrin du reste la
wii est alors un peu oui non mais en
même temps je suis peut-être romantique
mais tous les amis des gens qui
m'entourent et je pense d'ailleurs
l'image que j'ai dans le public
je pense pas que c'est quelqu'un qu'on
aime voir triste chanteur du bonheur et
mes amis je l'accepté pas très bien donc
heureusement il y en a certains qui
m'ont dit arrêtez arrêtez un peu v mais
bon c'était de ses chagrins qu'il faut
aller où il faut vraiment son fond c'est
pour après voir renaître mais tu penses
que en fait michel berger il la mettait
en valeur et toi tu te mettais savoir en
valeur c'est ça le problème nantes dire
une chose
celui jeu tout fait pour à la boîte
répondent sur moi ouais mais après je ne
veux pas empiéter sur leur vie de stress
et leur problème donc je me pose la
question à moi je te réponds très
sincèrement mais après je n'ai pas envie
de les porter donc moi je les dis mon
point de vue ouais il ta dernière
volonté ça serait quoi ma dernière
volonté ce tract échanges et espérer que
je laisse l'image de quelqu'un d'honnête
j'étais là dedans j'ai un père qui
quelle honnêteté même et la rectitude
intellectuelle et et pour moi c'est très
important c'est les gens qui sont dans
le fond d'eux-mêmes gentil et on peut on
peut avoir des accès de méchanceté et
puis ce bled évidemment ce monde étaient
toutes très gentil ce serait très
emmerdant - et très est très lisse mais
quand on est bon au fond de soi et quand
on est surtout honnête
intellectuellement et je suis fier
laisser l'image de quelqu'un de bon
j'aimerais donne est intellectuellement
c'est à dire en vérité qui sait jamais
trop trahi ce que j'ai fait et tous les
moments j'ai fait je les fais en toute
sincérité
ce ch'ti maja que j'aimerais c'est en
tant que le public c'est tout le reste
alain bashung bonsoir alors on l'a reçu
ici à quelques semaines ton complice
comme parolier halte et parolier boris
bergman qui nous a appris une bien
triste nouvelle puisqu'il nous a dit que
maintenant après novice c'était fini
quoi je me suis rendu compte d'un truc
on sait que
plus on se fréquentait comme ça plus on
parlait et on écrivait des chansons
il avait l'air de dire aussi que tu
étais devenu quand même très con
couleurs très quoi kooner c'est à dire
que tu étais avec chantal arthur les
quatre chats dans la maison oui mais
vous avez le même style de vie si
j'avais la preuve que sortir jusqu'à 9
heures du matin tous les jours
en face de belles chansons je crois on
continuera le fait à l'époque par mga
d'étrenner tous les matins ou de jaser
parce que c'était complètement tordue il
y avait des vieux films
il y avait sept dégueulis dans les
chiottes il se passait quelque chose de
touchant tu vois là rien c'est clean
comment tu vas tu
comme le tube you and i bon alors c'est
un peu le bilan de nos vies cela sur la
critique c'est parfait comme ça
ressemblait plus à appeler blessure qu'à
rio grande et la critique a été
dithyrambique les ventes ça s'est passé
comment on va on va dépasser son monde
arabe c'est bien lui donner
c'est complètement me rendre dans leurs
sous à sa guise en tentant savoir qu
elle a finalement même si c'était voulu
au fond de toi et avec le recul est ce
que la redescente après gaby après
verte' ça a été douloureux
maintenant on peut le dire moi ce que je
voyais c'était effectivement rien il ya
ces deux tubes qui à un moment donné on
montrait que je pouvais que cette
musique pouvait être rentable mais mon
but c'était arrivé à faire des albums
qui ne se vendent c'est pas seulement
avoir une espèce de tubes et ensuite tu
fais un truc sur scène qui est vraiment
toi et tu passes ton temps à expliquer
sa vie chez schizo je fais j'ai fait un
tube mais vous savez je fais d'autres
trucs
bon ça st j'avais pas envie d'être à
côté de mes pompes et je crois que le
les gens s'intéressent aux albums et
très là on va faire l'interview première
fois c'est de me souvenir
premier boulot geder mais j'étais un peu
la boulangerie ouais j'ai d un peu la
boulangerie je livrais des trucs que
j'ai livré des pièces montées pour
pour les communions pour les mariages
tous à leur donner une pièce c'était
avant la conteste ouais ouais premier
flirt
elle s'appelait marie jeunes avant
moi j'habitais dans une petit village
qui était tendance catholique elle
habitait dans un autre village 1 km et
celle c'était plutôt protestons il ya
des problèmes dans l'alsace on se
rencontre à mi-chemin dans l'alsace
ouais c'était l'enfer t'avais pas le
droit de jouer avec les petits lévy d'en
face comme tu dis dans la chanson
s'était coincée ou s il y avait les yeux
les protestants les cathos saas et du
cloud devrait il y avait des vieilles il
y avait des idées des vieux bouts de
règlements de compte qui datait de la
guerre et intel qui avait dénoncé l'
intérêt et une telle qu'ils avaient
couché réussite de l'hôtel avant elle la
france la france est la première fille
avec qui tu as fait la manche quand
souvient ouest une brune ouais c'était
pas terrible c'était la sortie d'un
cinéma on va s'y retrouver dans dans un
hangar entre entre une moissonneuse
batteuse et parce que tu es dans un
hangar
machines agricoles tu vas et
j'étais très vite fait vers 17 c'était
déjà mieux mes premiers garçons
commencer un premier garçon avait quitté
fait l'amour aubin
je suis encore vierge de ce côté là oui
oui oui je sais pas j'ai un jour je me
suis retrouvé dans un pieu avec un mec
comme ça il vendait comme un fouet et
même toucher à peine comme ça et moi je
voulais dormir voir entre eux j'étais
étonné par ce maître parce que je
faisais bande et je trouvais ça
fascinant c'était pas essayer non
maintenant fait hier c'est dangereux
tc gratin l'époque ça me paraissait
dangereux aussi
donc la tcar a pu à la première [ __ ]
ce sont 19 ans c'est pierre charon parce
que je chantais dans un dvd put rue
pierre charron by eva un pilote qui
s'appelait le club pierre charon j'avais
été engagée je devais avoir dix neuf ans
comme ça et je chantais cinq ou six
chansons tous les soirs avec une guitare
sèche
mon porte harmonica j'ai chanté des
chansons de dylan barry mcqueen
trucs comme ça yves destruction les
destructions à un grand moment parce que
ce très bien j'aime beaucoup et il y
avait des filles barre et puis j'étais
devenu copain avec m on passait des
nuits ensemble des fois ville matane ou
payés d'espagne
c'était super
le protéger car avant tu vas y aurait pu
mal tourner mais je les voyais pas comme
des sages et quand on me parle de cuite
je suis un peu choqué par le mou parce
que j'ai vu des filles superbes un
premier succès c'était beaucoup plus
tard on fait quoi
le premier succès cabine jusqu'à dit
rien c'était carrément oui on peut pas
appeler ça
il y avait du bricolage partout entre le
moment où tu as décidé de devenir
artiste et le moment où tafer gaby il
s'est passé combien de temps dix ans dix
ou en disant tu y as cru pas forcément
mais je rencontre toujours un conte qui
me disait écoute c'est bien ce que tu
fais
il est
c'est bizarre expliqué genre de truc
pourquoi tu insistes ou
c'est pas normal ce serait beau l'armée
ya peut-être certainement le fait que
j'ai essayé de bosser et essayer de
faire détruire j'essayais de
mais je sentais tellement que il y avait
que la vie pouvait pas être vraiment
fait avec et
une envie de gagner de l'argent comme ça
je préfèrerais mourir comme ça est
connue la compta chez péchiney je te
comprends visuel j'ai vu tout de suite
que complètement si j'avais été
comptable et un truc ça marche pas si
les musiques de films tu as fais plein
de jolies filles en effet cinq suspects
hélas comme un qui s'en sortent pas pas
une jeu ce soir
tu vas faire accéder un jour avec les
musiques de films de passion des mandats
temps j'aimerais j'aimerais bien c'est
sur un 24
quelque part je peux grand mix et un
jour
voir collector's ait un jour premier
million de nouveaux fronts oui quand je
devais avec bin ouais c'est ce qu'on a
fait je les ai pas vus en fait je les ai
pas vus beaucoup il ya tout de suite eu
des impôts j'étais en train de divorcer
ouais c'était un ramdam
incroyable c'est ça qui est fantastique
quand ça marche parce que tu vois très
grosse île et les choses fantastiques et
tu vois grossi aussi la connerie là et
la jalousie et tout ces trucs en plus
énormes ou sinon premier procès mon
divorce
ouais son peuple et sa prochaine ça
s'est arrangé quand même elle demandait
beaucoup elle a eu très peu a été dit là
bas elle demandait trop ou alors elle
fait attention à mon tour
celle où est ta dernière volonté tu
devais mourir ça serait quoi bon jeu
prendra un bain présentable à jouer à
touche pipi d'ilva thierry jean louis
aubert bonsoir salut alors je le dis
donc j'y pense et parce que si tu le dis
toi c'est moins bien
as tu fait l'olympia le 18 mai voilà ce
qui est des vieux volants faire le bilan
de bleu blanc vert là allons-y talent
avant de dormir d'abord aller voilà du
bac tu sais je sais pas ouais ça va
prendre combien pour cette fois
rentables c'est à 210 200000 le journal
chadi de cette poule dire je crois que
c'est ça mais je sais pas je suis pas
sûr que c'est pas toujours les bons
chiffres mais c'est pas fini quand
d'anciens dieux de l'album dont doublé
durée alors l'accueil critique tu penses
quoi de l'art critiques en france
c'est parce que ce qui se passe c'est
que laly - les coupes - les photos quand
j'étais petit ce que les
beaucoup de photos sur les murs
tu as tellement d'articles on peut
coller sur lyon qui veut dire non je
trouve que les gens parlent ils ont pas
énormément de plus toujours et ni de
coeur qu'on a fallu seulement qu'un peu
de bon sens peut changer avec la maladie
ça me touche moins qu'avant après le
premier morceau de la face à du 33 tours
tu sors le deuxième morceau de la face à
duran poitou près de poitiers
tuvalu tous essentiels le maximum
ouais comme comme l'album une assez
grosse panne est pour une fois ce matin
il à l'uniao tranche
je crois que le troisième ça sera le
troisième manche pas de problème je sais
absolument pas comment choisir sa caisse
a fait pour la journée de la terre
dimanche dernier toi qui fais un album
blanc vert je suis sûr que comme on est
dans une société un peu plus tôt
krassine société de consommation que ça
passera par les individus par les
consommateurs puisque on les appelle
comme ça j'ai une chance cette histoire
de la terre vraiment que ça va être quoi
que les gens vont arrêter de rouler en
voiture pour qu'en l'an 2000 la terre
soit propre
franchement je pense qu'on peut avoir
confiance dans le futur sais pas s'ils
vont arrêter de rouler en voiture parce
que lorsqu'on leur dit d'arrêter pour
leur voiture ils vont être arrêté de
rouler un peu parce que ils
travailleront sur leur compte twitter
chez eux et qu'ils n'auront pas aller au
boulot ils n'auront qu'à y aller deux
fois par semaine mais qui sont en
relation avec le monde entier
je crois qu'en fait la la communication
va peut-être résoudre beaucoup les
problèmes de déplacements qui sont quand
même des gros
gros pollueurs qui laisseront plus
couler l'eau quand il se lave les dents
c'est pas ça qui va changer la terre si
tu sais moi c'est un lavabo il apparaît
trop au fond et donc ces poulets ils se
rendirent et du fait pivoter c'est un
vieux truc et donc ça ça m'arrive plus
c'est java ouest france à s'y rendre une
fois passée la croissance 0,1 j'aimerais
bien qu'il ya une espèce démission comme
aux états unis où on désigne des
produits quand on sait ce que là par
exemple pour penser journée j'utilise
des petites piles au plomb là jusqu'à
pâques non bah oui mais je ne sais même
pas on n'a jamais dit de les ramener les
mais quand je vais ramène ils disent
qu'elles sont des gens fous tu connais
revendre a marre moi je trouve que à des
sourds franchement c'est si on trouve
pas de solution pour ces trucs pas il
faut carrément ne les jetez pas les
acheter damien draps de la bon j'ai posé
une question de compte comme ça que
vraiment vous invite à la pause et
depuis j'ai encore est-ce que tu
commences par le roi louis xi
je commence par les deux en même temps
enfin les paroles d'un côté à musique de
l'autre et ça se rencontrent ou pas bon
tu es prêt là on va faire une interview
première fois
[Musique]
première
mon premier souvenir piquer des les
truffes en chocolat dans un placard
jouer du piano dans un grand salon être
enfermé dans une cabane avec une grosse
araignée qui m'arrive de su monter à
cheval sur un canif à plat un
psychanalyste épaule n'a pas aujourd'hui
une fois tu arrives et le problème
j'ai pas les odeurs atrassi a tracé la
fenêtre regarder dans la ria de la
cuisine nantua dans l'ain ton premier
péché c'est sûrement même temps mené ça
pour être les truies farc est ici encore
c'est l'histoire d'une bonne plutôt que
ton père était sous préfet non ouais
c'est plein de vannes je vous fais ce
n'était pas vraiment pauvre pauvre comme
murray avec ça mais il y en a une qui
maquille mec qui s'appelait mignonne et
qui était assez charmante d'ailleurs
également menées dans les bureaux à le
montrer son derrière ça ne s'était pas
moi qui paie cher bien ton premier
fleurs
en provence antoine assis sur des troncs
d'arbres puis la france est montée sur
le tronc d'arbre qu'on a mis une après
midi à s'embrasser c'était très très
difficile
tu mettais la langue
je me suis renseigné auprès de mon
beau-frère papa le premier jour mais le
deuxième j'étais dire que c'est j'avais
appris un nouveau truc ta première cuite
c'était sur le
c'est sur le bateau venant d'angleterre
le malade à la une bouteille de whisky à
deux états
d'abord leur but
la météo même
ah bon jamais de l'argent pourtant j'ai
payé mes pas compact pour l'argent
même quand avec 15 rentes ai jamais eu
l'idée
[Musique]
non pas ce suis sûr que non je
réfléchisse bien sûr que non
première aventure chez lui avec un autre
garçon cette époque de la guerre des
boutons la guerre des boutons ça
m'excitait beaucoup quand ils attachent
le chipset et ouais j'avais un copain la
dette en 8e 7e enfin en général presque
tous mes amis à cet âge là ça se finisse
est toujours dans des 10 kg
un saut mal sous les tables des défenses
sent protégé par une table alors qu'elle
est maintenant
[Musique]
ça
maintenant ça a dit daly dans le guêpier
comptait pas peiné mais tu aimais bien
séduire les homos ça reste plateau de
wes et
jamais faire de bons jeux
l'a86 est une exigence de taizé clair
voilà mais par contre ça nous arrive d'y
penser en tournée particulièrement son
premier voyage t'en souviens qu'à
l'étranger
c'est l'angleterre pour l angleterre
l'angleterre il ya eu plusieurs je me
souviens qu'avec lui on faisait la
manche dans le métro avant avec guitar
ou jeu guitar but on a toujours notre
génome
et
je me suis un grand voyage c'était avec
olive on a traversé les états unis en
stop là je suis resté six mois je vous
l'aï dit à mes parents je reviendrai en
cadillac je serai riche parce que ici la
musique on y comprend rien à l'émeute se
passe là-bas la californie alors on est
arrivé à new york où il y avait louis à
nouveau et singe c'était très compliqué
on a mis une pancarte avec marc est
ouest dessus première banalisons
paraguay un truc on est parti de là nord
et s'est arrêté quatre mois comme ça
puis après j'ai joué dans un groupe à
los angeles et je suis revenu avec plus
de pompes
moi je savais ce que l'intérêt constant
pas par un ils étaient un peu sous
préfet mais mettez à la poésie non ouais
j'aime bien toujours est toujours très
vigilant on regarde bien ce que je fais
et on en voit aussi beaucoup d'articles
de journaux ont fait un peu la collecte
d'informations ce qu'ils pensent qu'il
pourrait me servir quelques façades
serbe par quelques fois ça me sers tu
vois je pense que je porte
faites un truc de génération en
génération pense que je porte des idées
qui va
peut-être la misson couverture m'a causé
la guerre la position sociale et c'est
ton premier pétard plus conciliant ouais
c'était quoi
dans ma piaule de bonnes je devais
réviser le bac est un copain audi veut
c'est le bon peuple
et voilà et c'était 2 du cadre du mazar
i sharif
j'étais complètement dingue et j'avais
jusque là était le chanteur du groupe à
cette époque là
on avait l'impression d'être dépuceler
d'une certaine manière en fait c'était
vraiment d'une certaine manière nous les
relatifs bons premiers votes parce que
tes parents l'avaient amenée à la manif
du général de gaulle le vrai le 30 mai
68 nom julien clerc aussi un jeu y'a pas
de vente eux se sont dits technoparc les
rites white vous étiez là c'est pas moi
je me souviens que le signal qui a un
gars qui est passé avec les gens mais un
peu maigre et tout le monde est aux
abois la mine où une voix la bible moi
ça m'est passé libye munis de bougies et
la bible ou non plus marrer jamais plus
voter alors alors j'ai jamais beaucoup
peut-être même même pour les veaux écolo
du mode pas bonne pour le chef de classe
à l'école côté les échos notre vote pas
pour eux non histoire je suis pas écolo
moi j'aime bien la terre j'aime la
nature je réfléchis à tous a cherché à
faire
fagni
ton premier souvenir c'était dans ma
chambre j'étais monté sur une petite
chaise que j'écoutais de la musique et
se faisait
il était chef d'orchestre un bâtiment
était mon frère et mon style pin-up
c'est ce mélange est vraiment là pour ta
mère et et concertiste était pianiste
julie à quatre mains tous les deux non
j'avais un professeur tapé sur les
doigts avec une règle pour le solfège
sinon c'était ma grand-mère map le piano
et puis étudie tout le monde croit que
je sors du conservatoire en fait c'est
pas vrai pagé aucune technique du
musical d'avoir crois que c'est un bon
pianiste qui est totalement seul un bond
très très bonne et il a appris à vivre
ltd faut alors oui mais aussi le premier
disque que tu as acheté sa série charmed
le premier match avec une pochette
blanche et intitulé j'ai dû faire à la
maison quand même temps c'est en tout
cas à l'intérieur la salle ça fait
vraiment quelque chose
la première fille avait quitté ses
labours bas étaient blancs parce que moi
je suis très partisane savoir plus sur
les banques mais vous ayez
c'était match et c'est comme lire de la
musique sans connaître la partition quoi
première fois c'était au but
j'avais un petit studio parce que très
très vulgaire se lier à oui parce que je
vais moins 15 ans j'ai commencé à gagner
en écrivant des chansons ce qui était
quand même très particulier et j'ai très
vite assez indépendant également tous
tuyaux et voilà le premier garçon à
l'hôpital fait l'amour est bien content
ça c'est une expérience que j'ai pas eu
mais en même temps j'ai beaucoup de
tendresse pour les gens qui aiment les
garçons seraient pas contre un ce serait
pas contre city alliée un truc fils est
mort
je suis incroyablement attirés par les
jeux ne doit pas avoir trouvé beau un
mec vraiment par exemple j'ai retrouvé
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'il ferait un
bon jour aucun tabou moral par rapport à
ses marques
la première chanson et c'est vrai que
c'est pour bourvil et que c'était la
girafe
ouais c'est ça la pipe à ce sujet qu'il
ya vraiment rien à voir ce que bourvil
faut maintenant mais c'était un type
extraordinaire moi j'étais je voulais
courir avec pour vivre tel directeur
artistique de cellules et pathé et qui
s'occupait de tout cela je me souviens
qu'ils étaient très c'était une époque
où c'était les jeunes qu'il est la loi
il avait envie de 8 de faire travailler
déjà le look a pourvu way et ont vu il
était formidablement
hier tout flou oui il avait fait part à
son tour nous parce que ce que vous avez
chanté moi c'est pas du tout mon truc
j'ai ce qui m'intéresse c'est les
beatles et et moi écrivez moi ça au
contraire chaleur va simplifier créer
une chanson pour lui il a absolument pas
gentil comme un truc c'est devenu dans
son bon rythme mais ça m'a permis de me
payer au parc est ce que tu as eu un
complexe quoi vis-à-vis du rock and roll
tu dis toujours je fais pas du recadrage
fait la retenue nous y faire de 10
rebonds s'est pas complètement du
rock'n'roll est ce que t'as pas été est
ce que vraiment et pas assez d un côté
bon élève et tu serais pas assez
distroll pour être vraiment rock and
roll ça c'est à l'intérieur ça se passe
et je pense que sept ministres oeil à
l'intérieur qu'à l'extérieur un handicap
par rapport à ça je parlais dans les
faits tout à l'heure ouais c'est clair
très sage quoi finalement west à leur
bon gars et bien habillés et
l'ancien intérieur certain que ça c'est
bien la première production c'est vrai
que c'était dur est vite fait
jesus est un album les règles car ça m'a
permis sa vision très longtemps mais
c'était un petit peu sur l'idée de boris
vian qui avait fait un ouais t'as ton
animé et nous on s'est dit on n'arrête
pas de nous dire oui l'ami américain
j'ai deux piliers intéressant alors en
effet pour les américains et on s'est
dit on va faire une liste c'est comme
chez la banque elle chante et cela
personne ne savait que j'étais nous
comprend et donc les programmateurs de
radio ont dit voilà ça c'est vraiment
dingue américaines et annoncé un
partenariat avec non c'est ça oui on a
été pêché un petit pour chanter en
anglais est atypique et en a vendu à
nice et à rabat in a million et après tu
a tout perdu en faisant un 33 tours
s'appelait puzzle voilà c'était quoi ce
polar j'avais gagné je vais me en deux
jours avec un arc et saint félix
je voulais faire un concerto avec un
groupe avec une guitare électrique une
basse et une batterie alors qu'elle
savait ni et là j'en ai vendu 300 jeux
et des colonies plus celle que je le
faire par la suite on était dedans mais
c'était un métier extraordinaire que
j'écoute des postes clés c'est inaudible
ton premier drame dans ta vie cet écran
le vrai de rendre concrète la peur de
mon frère et un proche y était
c'est lui qui m'a appris beaucoup
beaucoup trop de risques
la famille s'appelant toile s'est
suicidé aussi oui c'est vrai ça s'est
produit le drame
c'est un ami d'enfance avec lequel j'ai
facilité latence qui s'est suicidé le
pourquoi je crois que son histoire
d'amour
justement lui arrive ton premier amour
grand amour mais moi j'ai eu très peu
d'amour c'est à dire indique son premier
amant oui je crois que c'est à peu près
le premier important d'aller rompu
pourquoi tu sais que tu essayes qu'il
faut le demander qu'on lui a demandé ses
pour comparer c'est comme si on met pas
les munitions qui veut récolter son
deuxième quant à mon écoute je crois que
c'est la fille qui suit maintenant
on put voir séparément ces intermèdes
fidèles ouais assez
julien clerc nous a raconté que lui
quand elle était avec lui il était un
peu dans l'ombre et que toi au contraire
la mise dans la lumière trois que c'est
ça enfin dehors de d'amour qui avait
entre vous parce que c'est ça qui vous a
réuni ailier pour longtemps je sais pas
tu sais je crois que c'est très
difficile de dire pourquoi ça ça va d'un
couple gay après ça va plus je crois que
c'est très très difficile en tout cas de
passer sa vie avec la même personne
salaire de détournement des savates ans
est un miraculé jacques enseignants
certains de l'année ton premier succès
personnel
quant à chanter des chansons le premier
truc a vraiment marché de toit par toi
la robine pianic la coupe et du pianiste
ouais ça a été tout d'un coup ça a été
incroyable parce que tout d'un coup de
ménage la cité page et john john non
plus non c'était c'était déjà le
quatrième ou cinquième album
enfin à huy avait plein de gens qui
commençaient à transporter c'était c'est
un peu con en il était plutôt et
chansons pour les autres
d'autres grands exemple quand il ya des
moments un second j'arrête je fais des
chansons pleines et aux autres moi
j'arrive d'abord n'ont à aucun moment
non non c'est pas un peu près donc pas
mes cheveux blancs s'en souvient et en
quelle année moi je sais avant dix mois
on va voir vous avez remarqué
c'est vrai tu dois avoir des comme ça de
textes pleins de rêves 180 oui j'ai un
article une interview georges marc
benamou dans le quotidien de paris tu
viens à vous d'avoir ton premier sur le
gland et j'en ai tout à plat ouais je
savais absolument pas ce qui est arrivé
pour évoquer ton adolescence mais une
enfance et j'ai de faire une petite
interview première fois des prêts oui
première bo première boum un message me
rappelle de tout les boomers toujours
pareil m'inviter pour faire rire
la première partie de la soirée
puisqu'il est ce l'arrivée on me
demandait de rester près du buffet
j'étais dernier embrassé une fille
première idole premier rideau orlov
quand savoir jeudi que j'aime vraiment
beaucoup claude françois
tu connais toutes ses chansons par coeur
a pas mal pas mal mais je suis pas
fétichiste
on enregistre j'ai acheté un costume du
bio aux enchères est ce que tu sais qui
a écrit les lundis au soleil
ouais c'est un copain s'appelle pas
trébucher bravo pour l'applaudir
sa mère
premier flirt premiers flirts c'est dans
un autocar dans le fond avec la plus
belle en direction de l'italie
j'étais j'ai dit le dernier dans ma
classe de beach soccer il est à l'avant
je les avais de ma classe sortir avec
une fille ouais je sais bien passé quand
même bien ou bien j'ai pensé qu'on peut
pas respirer de finement s'il fut du
première cuite
la dernière c'est avant-hier alors la
première sur votre en butte au lycée
ouais ils ont su r pas particulièrement
non non non non je te bourrer du premier
vrai amour premier vrai amour ce doit
être un muret drogba je vous que je suis
là m'entendais bien amoureux d'elle
première expérience sexuelle
ah bah oui on m'a dit moi il fallait
absolument j'ai merde j'avais 19 ans
faut absolument que je suis passé à
l'acte à l'acte et je me suis renseigné
sur la fille la plus facile du lycée qui
est tout
c'est passé comme une lettre à la poste
1er juin 1er juin s'était longtemps à la
police et aux lions il ya pas longtemps
non au collège au collège du collège
fonds soit mais j'étais vraiment on
était fous quand et n'importe quoi on
fumait du café du thé premier procès
dans l'est pas encore non il ya non non
j'ai voulu en faire un point sur un cône
a rappelé wermus l'anis
qu'est ce qui t'as des grands reporters
du salon de thé qu'est-ce qui m'a dit
elle mais qu'il avait dit je vous le
rappelle rappelons le
pierre palmade n'est autre qu'un pâle
imitateur de sylvie joly donc ça m'avait
énervé quoi qu'ils le disent qu'ils ne
dévoilent premier vide premier bid se
soit 10 mois alors je vois tout ça
c'était pour t'amener pour remuer des
souvenirs d'enfance et d'adolescence je
suis très heureux
bah oui est ce que tu as fait longtemps
pipi au lit
pas plus que je m'en souvienne ta mère
tu en parles pas là tu en as quelque
chose qui a marqué dans la famille non
on va faire une interview première fois
ah ouais vas faire ton premier souvenir
par exemple c'était comment je me suis
retrouvé à avoir un caniche au lieu d'un
mouton et ben j'avais été au marché
qu'elle était dans mon village à maywand
et j'étais tombé mais complètement
amoureuse d'un petit mouton tout blanc
mignon je devais avoir quoi quatre ans
et je dis je veux le mouton je veux le
mouton et jetez la même époque mais
mignon et ma mère me dit écoute on va
rentrer à la maison et on reviendra tout
allant le chercher parce que tu vois je
suis chargé tout ça et je fais bon ben
d'accord
sachant très bien n que le marché s'en
allèrent une heure
elle me rama nathan
le mouton tu vois il est parti mais là
je n'ai pas bougé je me suis jetée par
terre ça a été terrible il a fallu aller
chercher mes grands parents et mon grand
père a dit attends via la maison je te
promets que je vais tram n'est peut-être
pas un montant mais quelque chose qui
ressemble est allé le chercher un
caniche honneur très belle histoire
ton premier baiser dans la cage
d'ascenseur
parce que tu dis pas tu as dit que en
fait le coup de la langue que vous avez
vues dans union parce que chez toi quand
tu étais petit y avait des revues comme
ça qui traînait avec l'union
et puis avait des revues qui venait
dessus elle aussi a été vraiment gentil
couple à l'enjeu l'évident union si tu
savais ce que j'ai vu dans l'union et
dans d autres produits qu'ils n'ont
souvent jamais chez vous
visible à long terme a une chance d'y
aller partout car il y avait de tout
absolument dans cette vidéo c'était
assez jeudi il s'agit des compositions
absolument c'était des pages pleines et
en tombe au père à l'époque tu as vu en
train de lire en cachette ces revues qui
l'a remarqué que l'elysée parce que je
l'avais parmi tout à fait à la bonne
heure c'est à dire en fait tu as besoin
de te cacher pour lewis à nous emmerder
qui m'en parlent mais moi je dis oui je
sais je sais y'a pas de problème est en
fait lui avait pas de produit c'est
beaucoup moins drôle si c'était permis
non non c'était passé assez
qu'absolument en passa toute façon je le
faisais dans dandy dit c'était permis
moi je n'ai jamais eu le sentiment que
c'était interdit
non c'était pas fêté que c'était comme
une intrusion dans mon intimité érotique
idem pour effectuer eux mêmes ne peut
pas dire honte à dire tous étaient tout
à fait qu'ils se balader à poil à la
maison mais tout le monde se balader à
poil
et maintenant canet
même le canis ta première expérience
sexuelle
c'est à dire la chose c'est qu'a dit la
chose sexuelle
ça veut dire quoi tu veux savoir quoi
exact la première fois tu t'es fait
sauter et précis a non mais si tu n'as
absolument pas précis parce que dans la
première fois que tu t'es ses soutes et
je peux te dire mardi matin 11 heures
la première fois dans ta vie ni d'un
hardy matin 11 heures ça répond à ta
question n'est pas précis statut 13 ans
et demi en fait non je vais te dire ma
question je veux savoir si c'était ton
ton parolier duval outans compositeur
allen ski parce que je sais pas très
bien mais coutu leur demandera ta
première télé c'était en belgique
c'était une émission qui s'appelait
choix génération 80 elle traque
or vous savez vous me avance maintenant
ça va tu as pu le trac sigean que
j'avais encore le trac en fait ce soir
j'ai pas le train est donc au bilan
le premier bide finalement je sais pas
c'est peut-être quand j'ai signé mon
premier contrat disent que j'aurais
peut-être dû réfléchir à deux fois j'en
sais rien mais en tout cas je sais que
mon premier beau bid c'était quand
j'étais enceinte ça ton premier noël
je m'en souviens pas de particuliers
mais je me souviens bien de la
préparation autour de noël
un an gwan au portugal parce que on
aller avec mon grand père coupait un
sapin à la tombée de la nuit j'ai eu dix
équipera connaît enfin je suis même pas
sûr c'était dans un terrain derrière
chez lui mais ça participe est
complètement l aventure c'était bien
espionné l'été lire la mousse au pied
des arbres pour en tapisser la crèche
dis moi tu veux faire une interview
première fois justement sans rapport
avec les marouani et tout ça une vraie
interview première fois en suisse ou à
l'école et ben ouais ils sont travaillés
tout à marriott
dis moi ton premier souvenir cinq ans
ouais qu'un anniversaire et un
anniversaire dans une dans mon petit
village à juillac avec des éléphants
dessinée sur le mur tout ce que je me
souviens quand mes souvenirs je crois
que c'est ça c'est assez nette
d'ailleurs cinq ans ma grand mère habite
dans un petit truc avec la radio sur la
table très bien où tu avais pas ton père
tu m'as tu es né de père inconnu
tu peux les coeurs comme tu veux mais
j'ai aussi né de père inconnu et étudie
finalement c'est très bien comme ça
ouais ouais ouais c'est très bien comme
ça on va dire que c'est très bien comme
ça ouais ouais ça parce que ça m'a
motivé sam à ta revanche enfin connue
non je le connais tu connais maintenant
je le connais j'ai fréquenté pour enfin
j'ai croisé pendant des années il ya
quelques temps j'ai paris et puis il
reste inconnu table pour lui sa première
balle sur deux que les copains l'école
parce que justement c'était de faire un
coup et c'est pas ta mère non sûrement
pas surmontant ta mère s'appelait dd ça
fait toujours des mets et elle avait un
côté un peu non comme la merde depardieu
on peut bien que parce que des parties
d'une mère comme ça un peu c'est ça un
peu l'avenir ma mère ma mère c'est plus
que la moitié de moi ci est le jouet 100
most ramasser à la petite cuillère
et puis ça c'est un rocher c'est plus
qu'un rocher temps premiers flirts tu
t'en souviens way lorette s'appelait
ouais c'est une rousse j'ai embrassé sur
la joue je suis parti en courant way
c'est content j'avais 10 ans 10 ans en
cède bien ta première sans gêne j'ai une
mémoire fait j'adore cette époque
première cuite
la première rupture je me rappelle bien
chaque des potes avant de avant la
veille de la rentrée des classes on l'a
fait quelque chose quand même c'était
bon c'est beau à la gueule à l'isara à
sucre et non à boire c'est dur à vomir
c'est sucré oh la la c'est l'horreur et
tu sais ce qu'on avait fait tellement on
était bourré on a voulu faire du café
gala je ne conseille à personne faut
vraiment être tordu pour le faire on a
pris la machine à laver
on a mis le café voulu dans le truck
coutumes et la poudre à l'époque il y
avait un tuyau qui sortaient les
saloperies mais on attendait que la q1
c'était dégueulasse avait acheté sur
tommy cash dont 600 balles c'est ça non
non tu es fou car 30 francs ces 30 bal à
l'époque l'avait au panier c'est 30
francs le pénitencier c'était 30 francs
le port du salut c'était 40 francs
c'était en 74 c'est pas si vieux que ça
c'est un peu dur pour bouffer quand même
temps premier bid au peuple avec les
gonzesses qu'est-ce que j'ai pris on va
voir remarque maintenant j'ai appris un
arrêt j'ai appris mais non tu sais les
nanas moi j'ai pu j'étais vachement
complexes et un grand nez soyez tout
était trop grand
et comme les éléphants ouais pareil j'ai
deux choses de l'éléphant j'ai la
mémoire aussi et puis en plus pendant
des années je j'ai essayé je me faisais
des moches pas et un jour enfin on va
aller jouer autant je me faisais des
films et puis un jour je me suis dit
pourquoi tu essaies répond elle est
belle mais elle est très belle
celles qui sont sur la couverture des
magazines étouffé aussi chaque fois j'en
croise il non non c'est pas pour moi
avez-vous est en fait faut oser est-ce
que c'est pas plus dur mais pas avant
longtemps dans sa vue est même des fois
tu te demandes si les belles sont pas
plus facile qu'avant plus l'habitude
c'est sur une cale s'emballe ben ouais
mon premier mariage a c'est très bien
c'est génial c'est 15h30 non non non
c'est un an et demi 16 ans et demi
saison il n'y a qu'une dispense du
président de la république vous avez
tiré ensemble non être fou puis j'ai
assumé tout de suite et j'assume et tout
de suite j'ai voulu j'ai voulu faire
bouffer ma femme gosses c'est tout donc
je me suis mis à bosser
j'ai même passé un concours de flics que
j'ai pas eu heureusement [ __ ] tu
t'imagines juste ranger ma forme est en
danger les ratés dans le point tu te
rends compte deuxième mariage on
n'oublie pas ceux qui ont parlé de sa
gauche troisième mariage les trucs chez
toi du quatrième cas connus ou c'est
connu c'est un copain qui m'a présenté
sur un plateau et puis après on s'est
connu à val d'isère dans un gala j'étais
parti que les cocos coeur et je me
disais dans la catégorie coco girl il
manque un truc à ma collection
ouais c'est jab moment je sais c'est
vrai que je reconnais que j'ai fait je
me suis fait un challenge à savoir je
vais taper speakerine machin spirale
plus
coco girl en fait c'est parti comme ça
et je ne suis pas du tout partie avec
mais j'ai vu que cette fille là si elle
mettait la main dessus
c'était cuit et on en fait on sait le
hasard c'est une chose bête on sait on
s'est vraiment connu le soir où connu
chez mort parce qu'elles habitaient chez
coluche c'était une amie de coruche un
ami tout bien tout habitiez habiter chez
coluche et puis on sait
on s'est téléphoné soir commission le 19
juin 86 on s'est revus on s'est mariés
on a fait un petit lait né le 19 juin
91 c'est bizarre ça va et entre-temps
coluche s'est tué en moto et mon fils
c'était aussi un hasard à savoir c'est
vrai que le petit benjamin
quel âge il a six mois ouais c'est vrai
qu'il ya déjà coupé quatre fois les
cheveux défi c'est comme toi c moi je
les peurs tech à lui mais lui il a les
cheveux ses monstrueuses jamais vu ça
tombe bien sûr qu'il est à toi
ah ouais ouais tu vois semble même s'il
était noir il sera bon ouais vrai pour
une interview première fois oui c'est la
première fois que l'on fait sécher par
agent moussant j'amènerai premier
souvenir en cinq ans cheminée j'ai sorti
du ventre de maman et il y avait plein
de gens blancs qui me regardait en riant
ouais ma maman une florennes c'est froid
premier péché une première fiche n'est
pas ma maman elle était abonnée au
quinté le thermolactyl de damart et un
jour je les feuilleter en cachette comme
ça j'étais un inconnu
j'ai des pensées impures première boum
qui n'est pas méchant la première boum
et vomi pourquoi
as ne me convainc pas et maurice boivin
whisky coca
sauf qu'ils avaient oublié de main du
clan 15
la première idole moins mal en point les
pommes win un premier fleurs alors à
charles ix lisa mais taylor mais lisa
mais taylor d'aujourd'hui estime
première cuite tamanrasset cessé à
droite ou à gauche
[ __ ] monde
sexuelle
c'est avec une boîte de cirage mais tous
les ans tu m'avais atteint chien d'armes
après il fallait en toi et chante un pin
bigerri lapin organes
parlons premier voyage le premier voyage
je m'en souviens pas que c'était un
système par la fenêtre celte on prend
bien celui-là est ton premier choix
alors ça c'est un genre mes parents ils
vont garder
je pense que oui c'est un genre j'ai une
randonnée avec mes camarades dans la
forêt et on avait décidé d'attraper des
crapauds pour les faire fumer
steven problème c'est qu'on n'a pas
attrapé un crapaud quoi c'est moi et il
en est fini
le succès mon premier succès saison j'ai
réussi un personnel marchand de journaux
de novembre pente aux titres
indépendants c'est le journal où tu vois
tout ce qu'il ya dedans les dames et
dégueulasse première interview
première interview à la tv instance
était nulle part ailleurs
avec monsieur philippe gildas et je
tiens à lui rendre hommage parce que
c'est un grand monsieur
enfin non
et ta dernière volonté ça serait quoi
gentil moins je peux le dire
bah si tu veux oui laurent temps de la
monarchie comme ça c'est moi qui
comprendrait je pourrai manger
est ce que tu es prête pour faire et
même pas vu première fois première baffe
je n'ai jamais été giflé par mes parents
sans en parler copine sa charge mais par
les hommes
sympa non un bon jamais à le premier qui
essaye on va faire les pourtours premier
noël premier noël
oui j'avais une jaunisse
je me souviens j'avais une très belle
robe de chambre jaune assorties
justement majalis ses tout premiers
objets fétiches d'amour ce dont j'avais
arracher les oreilles et les yeux tu la
gardes et j'ai toujours tueur avec non
c'est pas avec lui que tu dois premier
péché premier péché qu'est-ce que j'ai
pris en compte dès qu'ils ont un rôle à
l'ag de trop d'enfants tu sais tiens moi
mon premier match et si je peux pas le
raconter à la télé on va déjeuner entre
nous dans l'été deux petits copains
comme ça on était jeunes et avec l âge
cet engin a déjà annoncé passage
tu joues à quoi dans le jeu des petites
j'étais chef de bande
tu joues et tu préférais jouer quand il
était petit à cache-cache au docteur à
cache cache jamais joué tellement
docteur fou même si j'ai chanté docteur
j'étais juste une première boum
j'avais 19 ans et demi est resté dix
minutes pas plus couplés pour ckoi qui
ne plaisait pas les filles les garçons
soient serrés les uns contre les autres
les repères
ah ouais j'ai fait le service militaire
dont sa vie savoir du bassin première
idole c'était kit dorothée à toi c'était
fred astaire ginger rogers et surtout au
très bon premier flirt ou t'en souviens
c'était qui en angleterre où il était
grand très grand très grand que s'ils
s'étaient passés exactement sur quelle
gifle à tous ces gens qui vous ça
continue d'être un petit peu plus sur la
première cuite
certainement après un spectacle après ce
jeu de la vérité de chantal deuil
sympa ce premier amour bon je ne fais
pas ce que je te parle d'amour quand
même des muscles et y parvient c'est le
maintien
quelques bars pour monsieur bashing je
crois qu'il ya un bon contact avec la
dame claire manavit sont musclés fait
gaffe et sur 500 euros là aussi il y en
a sans effet mais sa grâce à un bon
premier amour alors hausse était très
gentil très très très romantique
derrière mon type bon première
expérience sexuelle
ça s'est très bien passé merci c'est
vers quel âge à cet art là aussi
d'avant-hier veut battre les phillies
ont fait gaffe
c'était vers quel âge au j'avais 18 ans
quand même oui et alors c'était très
beau faire garder un bon souvenir
tu la revue non à ces cas c'est le même
arrivé 1er juin tu as fumé
j'avais jamais fumé de dollars je crois
qu'on écoute si tu as dit qu'on allait
être sincère mais le dr bon d'accord
premier succès
côté télé côté 10 côté premier succès de
tête vit la première fois où tu t'es dit
tiens ça y est ça marche
y'a pas d'hier non il n'a pas d'hier
mais rien ne prendre que deux claques
dans la gueule
premier succès je crois que c'est où la
menteuse je crois ou là vraiment je
quand dans la dans la rue les gens m'ont
dit à la menteuse on est amoureuse c'est
quand les gens dans la rue te parle et
le coup ça a bien marché à new york
premiers millions d'anciens francs n'y a
pas très longtemps il n'y a pas très
longtemps
il est dit que j'ai battu là bas il a
peur du toile je m'attends chez c'est la
première fois que je mets quelqu'un de
torches et s'évite un bravo premier
million de nouveaux faux je sais pas à
temps honnêtement j'en sais rien sur mon
compte tu sais pas ce que tu me dis
attention des thons rouges bomba
d'accord attention tout passe dans la
drogue le premier geste que tu fais le
matin je râle je croyais c'est une
question piège alors qu'est ce qu'elle
est grâce l'écologie qu'est ce que tu
fais le matin c'est pas allumer la tv
non cette deuxième c'est comme mtv chez
toi une dans chaque pièce
ça fait combien tu sais qu'on est le 21
mars et le 1er kouassi le 21 mars attend
d'être un temps premier jour du
printemps
et oui du moi toi et toi tu es prêt toi
aussi envie de cannes est un battant
c'est à l'oreille après le home energy
me casse mon prend l'eau à chaque
adresse un coup d'abord
j'espère une interview première fois des
prêtres ou 1 on est dans l'enfance dans
les enfants dans les mamans les papas
thon rouge pêché
j'en ai tellement le premier que tu as
fait avec une petite caméra lui revenir
un tien
jouer à touche pipi a causé un mort
c'est très marrant je sais que c'était
mes potes avec les coûts des indemnités
a choisi d'épouser mes copains d'épouser
invité parce que moi c'est que je vais
revoir maintenant et que je doive céder
messieurs ah je pensais arriver
peut-être coup je m'en souviens que tu
vois je me dis second remake barbu et où
je suis avec lui et évidemment pas non
il s'en souvient pièce qui périssaient
qui s'en souvient absolument pas légions
résistante leur mémoire mais je crois
que les enfants jouent moins touche pipi
non on jouait beaucoup tu veux pas
touche pipi moi j'y joue tout le temps
quand j'étais petit je jouais aussi bien
s'aimer sans voix que les enfants de
maintenant moi je sais pas moi j'ai deux
filles pour le moins elle son petit je
sais pas encore je te dirai ça dans
quelques temps d'ici lundi je vous dis
je
c'est pas apprécié non à cauchy sûrement
pas un pêcheur vraiment un péché pas
mettre à la tête des surtout dans la
première boum première boum
premier round 12 13 ans qu'est ce qui a
fait rouler des pelles les dlc ça je
suis arrêté là haut on avait très très
vite et torch est un peu moins c'est ce
qu'on disait l'époque n'ont prononcé
médias non c'était des pétards et des
pétards des jeunes gens venant
entre-temps un peu plus vieux quand même
moins 13 ans n'hésite pas à marcher ou à
tous prix les pétards sa mère d'une
copine premiers flirts c'était la
première fleur c'était dans une boum
il ya eu baisers profonds ou sympathie
oui mais le vrai le vrai des épreuves au
calendrier la première fois que tu t'es
retrouvé toute nue avec un garçon aux
jeux thq et tenait à et lui donc
c'est très serré j'ai surpris que ça
sonnait tout droit sur tout ouais sous
une douche à lui l'arrivée sous la
douche non c'était ça a commencé en bas
comme tout bon que tous les garçons qui
aiment vraiment ça s'est mis en route et
ça m'a tellement étonné que du coup ça
m'a déconcentré et après je suis plus
donc on coucher pas si facilement quand
même à l'époque
ouais bah justement on y arrive première
expérience sexuelle mais avec
pénétration s'explique clairement une
patience qui ait pas d'ambiguïté je ne
sais pas si j'ai une vie de famille de
trois enfants
très très mignon fait j'étais très
amoureuse d'un garçon qui était très
amoureux de moi et on est restés
ensemble pendant cinq ans ah bah c'est à
dire mais je garde un bon souvenir de
cette première télé fera sinon c'était
vraiment une paire désignant un choix
comme vous pour pleins pleins d'anadys
la première fois tu dis quoi c'est ça
c'est un peu déçu et un peu des
premières expériences homosexuelles
d'expérience c'était l'époque je suis ta
génération il fallait tout ici c'était
est où ici alors on a tout essayé même
la télé même et alors je m'étais dit tu
étais vraiment ringard c'est avait pas
une expérience homosexuelle
moi ça me disait rien du tout mais je
lui disais que mourir que d'être
ringarde
donc j'avais repéré une nana qui était
plus plus du gazon maudit tu pouvais pas
fait et je m'étais dit bon va falloir
que je mal face à ne pas pas ça ne veut
rien du tout il faut que j ai quand même
tu vois et puis
j'y suis allé malheur bourg et comin
quoi et puis je ne sais pas ce qui s'est
passé
le seul truc c'est vraiment un matin
elle m'a dit est donc t'es pas une
affaire ah ouais c'est a pu recommencer
si tu fais ça me fait pas plus fier
c'est n'avait pas beaucoup plu puis
surtout c'était pour l'avoir fait toi
par mois je les fais je suis tu l'as
fait d'être ok je suis tranquille
première par tous ça c'était à satiété
et ça c'est les jeunes doit maintenant
ils sont comme ça il faudrait point c
était donc saisir ses grands parents
toutefois si bien dire j'étais chez un
camarade je suis un camarade qui me dit
viens on va chez des amis boire le verre
lave toi on s'échange des culottes ans
et j'aime
non pas du tout je ressentais un petit
ami de l'époque et tout puis on arrive
dans cette boue mais on était jeunes on
avait 15 16 ans tu voies privées des
matelas partout on était les premiers
mois j'ai pas vu le truc venir toi et
puis au bout d'un moment vont les gens
comme un simple toit a flirté tout ça
mais bon c'est dit je me suis dit bon
toi il est vrai un peu forme après tout
après la commande qu'ils y ont commencé
à ceux dé saper et au bout de deux
heures tout le monde était franchement a
poli avec moi qui va crochète peuple
et puis là il m'a dit quand même
attachement coincé comme dana et tout
est là j'ai dit ouais je cherche ma
pensée comme nana détail un effet nous a
regardé quand même non non non non je
suis parti j'étais assez moment je te
promets non mais pourquoi aujourd'hui
rock et on continue deuxième parfumant
surtout complet
alors la première cuite
voilà je suis souvent bourrés parce que
je vois pas beaucoup donc je suis très
vite bourré et comme les gens qui
boivent pas beaucoup je suis vite vos
années tester jeunes à problèmes des
jeunes aux huîtres sûrement oui mais je
sois pubiens premier pétard alors ben
une la mère d'une copine de classe dont
1 co 12 ans ou là un petit peu tous ces
thèmes développés tard toute façon une
expérience 12 ans tu tapes lutte avec
leur culpabilité gonflé brun way premier
incident jamais chez son mari n'ont
jamais d'acier parce que j'ai vraiment
là je trouve que les mecs ils étaient
tellement collé au bol d un wagon quand
même mon coin et régis et on connais
bien maintenant une espèce de regard
content que ça vous oubliez de se couper
les cheveux à wil toiture les hobbits
ah oui lascoux question interview we
have to practice michaud
sophie roman la face job de directeur
dana white bio l'astro maintenant tu vas
laisser sa place à hypo qua non ça va
moi je bouge plus maintenant mais c'est
un tout
[Applaudissements]
bon il faut oui j'ai tiré à blanc ne
parler du film souhaite faire une petite
interview première fois ses premières
fois c'est quoi première fois par
exemple devenir ton premiers souvenirs
bons ou mauvais souvenir c'est un rêve
ouais c'était quoi
c'est un loup est un renard qui ne
parlent dans un jardin et qui vient de
me dire que l'herbe pousse à ce moment
là je regarde
non c'est sérieux c'est un vrai salon
par le vexer et je regarde vers le ciel
et je vois une fenêtre qui s'ouvre
j'essaye de parler à cette fenêtre cette
fenêtre ne répond pas j'étais pas dit-on
premier pétard jeté mon premier souvenir
c'est la première baffe la première
baffe en fait la première dont je me
souvienne c'était dans une île il ya un
mec qui m'a chopé parce que je parlais à
sa copine enfin tout à fait banale et il
m'a chopé je les entends d un salon je
me souviendrai égoïste négoce c'est pas
beau ton premier objet fétiche tu t'en
souviens bien c'est dit fred est tout à
fait clair
la première dream au fond la colle et le
mec dans son coin comme ça vous arrive
et j'ai maintenant je prie d'en cesser
sa première boîte à malice riz ouais
t'as première idole meriden ouais j'ai
peu idole mais pas une idéale si
peut-être un peintre que j'aimais
beaucoup qui s'appelle paul klee mais
c'est tout
c'était pas mike brant où il a dit un
peintre il n'a pas d'une tâche ton
premier amour vrai amour mon premier
vrai amour
cen'est m'a tuer la tête et j'ai ramé
comme un dingue pour la voir j'ai
vraiment ramé ramé le jour j si c'était
bon que j'ai réussi à faire à une
combine avec sa soeur copain à moi un
truc incroyable juste pour la voir elle
et j'ai pu en mobylette c'était superbe
jusqu'à mon [ __ ] c'est génial ça
marche on a eu un accident tout autre
conception de la gueule single arracher
la triste ça c'est mon premier amour en
mêlée mais vachement première expérience
sexuelle ça s'est passé plus calmement
non ces gens pareils séjour incluant
incroyable et tout l'été jean dernier
moment c'était genre
la porte qui s'ouvre dans le couloir
voisin dans la chambre la porte s'ouvre
dans le couloir un bruit jean marc
cherry et à part moi qui suis de partir
par l'arrêt pour nous casser mais
l'expérience sexuelle sa première cuite
la première cuite massacres commis
cherche à me taper puisque c'était
bourré côté bourg et tapas de sévir
premier président richard parce que
premier pétard le premier pétard je me
souviens d'une grande parade non la
première vraie grande parano direct le
premier pétard ça c'est clair
premiers acides première a cité le seul
s'est jetée jamais redescendu ça m'a
collé girard était c'était à la campagne
ouais j'ai fait que tout cas ce qu'a vu
parce que non j'ai rien vu je peux plus
je fais ça parce que c'est vrai j'avais
mes doigts comme ça donc c'est le coup
j'ai vu mes doigts qui fit genre bon ça
c'est vrai qu'il est arrêté après j'ai
arrêté tout de suite c'est vraiment
spécial
ton premier succès ses premiers succès
ouais c'est quoi un succès
j'ai pas mon métier succès est amputé
ouais c'est un succès que j'ai vachement
plus tard ouais mais avant je n'avais vu
des petits quoi genre en ferait du bien
ouais jean le bon plaisir ça m'a
vachement du bien qu'on fort saganne
aussi son dauphin manon et puis le
vermont magnifique aussi la première
télé tu t'en souviens en tournage je te
dis où on un terrain comme ça on
invitait on éviter ou à donner à cette
pierre tchernia qui m'invite pour faire
gens sont les missions qu'ils allaient
et mardi cinéma
ouais mardi cinéma c'était au moment où
il y avait des manistes on est à la rue
peut-être 80 système d'étudiants et
d'étudiantes et je sais pas j'ai
commencé à me prendre la tête avec un
truc sur astérix
un film qui étaient faits en face et je
me suis échauffé tout seul moi j'ai
gueulé
je me souviens très bien que les deux
charnières mady mère vous savez parler
aussi ses sympathies je suis moi bien ça
pourquoi tu veux pas aller à sacrée
soirée
c'est quoi ces accessoires
c'est vrai
tu travailles comme ça et tu fais des
exercices pour améliorer ton nom
mêlerons pas un acteur qui a beaucoup
travaillé avant justement dont tu
travailles way et je suis obligée de
travailler avant de caler film sur
déroule parce que je suis pas bon et
c'est vrai que tu fais des exercices
pour apprendre à rire je fais dit
insiste pour essayer de pouvoir
peut-être un tout petit peu donné l'idée
que ça pourrait être un but
pour soir thierry alors on va prendre
les choses par le commencement on va te
faire une interview première fois est ce
que tu aimerais tu tout à fait prêts bon
alors ton premier non c'est pas du tout
enrico macias renoncer gaston ghrenassia
ghrenassia exactement parce que ma
première pochette c'était gaston
ghrenassia oui et le directeur de
commercial de ma maison de première
maison de disque et il n'arrivait jamais
à se rappeler de mon nom y est alors il
a demandé à ce que je le change
moi ça ne me plaisait pas tellement mais
enfin bref j'ai dit bon je vais le coupé
comme j'étais déjà coupé une première
fois je vais couper beaucoup de bagram
elle attend premier prénom c'est gaston
gaston alors où gaston c'est formidable
parce que moi je voulais le garder
j'ai toujours eu du succès à l'école
avec des seins à chaque fois on me
disait comment comment tu t'appelles
gaston barben ça faisait marrer tout le
monde oblige était le copain de tout le
monde
mais prenez pas mal quoi qui t'appelle
encore gaston personnes ainsi 6 mai à 13
mais ma femme avant mais mes copains
intime ceux qui m'ont connu depuis le
début ils m'appellent pas enrico alors
ton premier souvenir c'était rue
biscarra constantine non oui c'est ça
gulbis carraway il y avait des
catholiques y avait des juifs et des
musulmans qui vivaient ensemble sans
beaucoup de problèmes à l'époque là bas
oui surtout que moi je suis né dans un
quartier il
il faut dire que à constantine avait
trois quartiers bien distincts le
quartier juif le quartier chrétien le
quartier musulman mais moi je suis né
dans un quartier où toutes les
communautés étaient réunis alors il n'y
avait pas du tout de problème tant
premier choc dans la vie c'était quoi la
guerre d'algérie c'est sûr mais les
premiers attentats de salins les bombes
du saas ça ça me tue et ça c'est un truc
qui m'a qui m'a profondément choqué
parce que j'ai pas eu de jeunesse de
l'enfance on est passé directement aux
épreuves aux responsabilités ta première
guitare
je me rappelle quand j'étais tout petit
g
j'allais chez vous chez le menuisier je
prenais une planche et puis avec une
boîte d'allumettes
et puis des élastiques que j'arrive à
faire un petit instrument mais mon
premier instrument m'a été offert quand
même ma grand-mère et ça je n'oublierai
jamais ces fous de toi tes grands
parents
bah oui et moi j'étais fou mais grand
par le talent et 12 en étant premiers
amours ses sujets ma femme mais ouais
elle t'a abordés par les caves et des
nattes avec des petits noirs au bout des
nattes lt abordé dans l'alto tu avais
honte d'être en culottes courtes c'est
vrai ça oui c'est à dire que comme
j'étais un peu trapu et non c'est non
mais moi je me rappelle de suzy quand on
était petits c'était si t'es pas elle
qui m'a abordé et c'était moi qui ramait
pour le prologue pour la b parce que
pour qu'elle ait dit oui j'ai mis du
temps
alors ton premier voyage en france et
s'est passé comment c'est ton père
voulait te mettre dans une école juive
traditionnelle en france pour y aller tu
es resté dix minutes comment ça s'est
passé
je crois que tu es au courant beaucoup
tu sais pas non c'est vrai c'est une
aubaine extraordinaire un jour je dis à
mon père papa il ya plus de professeurs
c'est la guerre et où il n'y a pas un
moyen de partir j'ai une bourse je peux
avoir une bourse devrait continuer mes
études en france là au moins je pourrai
avoir des diplômes et tout et puis
j'arrive à le convaincre c'était la
maman ma première la première fois que
j'arrivais à convaincre mon père et ma
mère surtout mon père qui était un peu
dur avec moi mais enfin je regrette pas
maintenant on ne va pas c'est que genoux
les gardes et voilà que j'arrive donc il
m'a inscrit dans une école juive puis
j'arrive je suis reçue par la directrice
de l'école puis elle me dit comment vous
appelez jeudi ghrenassia gaston tu
saches et je viens de constantine est
dit et vous n'avez pas la kippa philippe
pourquoi il faut une kippa pour venir à
ces plaintes synagogue c'est une école
elle me dit il faut une kippa je suis
plus retourné et là tu es allé au lycée
carnot à fontainebleau oui j'avais un
cousin qui était
étudiant à l'époque et j'ai c'était un
de mes seuls parents avec ma tante il a
fait soeur de mon père et je lui ai dit
il faut que tu me trouves une école
parce que je vais être obligé de
retourner à constantine et sa juge veut
pas enfin c'est le bot a découvert le
racing c'est vrai un jour un type qui
t'a dit moi les juifs premier jour je
suis arrivée je le pris en plein dans la
gueule c'était un
un élève com - pensionnaires il
s'appelait de lamaze rappellerai tout
tout le temps et il m'a pris pour un
musulman pour un algérien de là bas
comme je suis bronzé j'ai le type n'est
pas le type suédois influent de ces
ballons ils me regardent comme ça puis
me dis attention moi j'ai rien contre
les arabes mais par contre une race que
je ne supporte pas c'est les juifs
bon je lui ai donné un coup de poing
mais voilà au conseil de discipline ne
voulait pas dans le dans le club du vice
et de fontainebleau
il faisait un peu la gueule il voulait
pas trop et puis un jour il ya un décor
s'est effondré et a commencé à jouer
comme ça c'est vrai ça oui c'est vrai
c'est une pièce de de prévert puis moi
jouer leur le rôle d'un capitaine et
j'avais une phrase un mot à dire en
avant il a dit virer plus forte j'ai pas
réussi à j'ai dit quand même il faut que
je fasse quelque chose
j'ai dit je savais je chante et je joue
de la guitare l'ange de les chanter une
chanson de mon pays je veux tibet qu'est
ce que c'est ça non non ça n'a pas
marché mais il a fallu que à la fête du
lycée de fontainebleau j'ai une chance
inouïe
le décor de la pièce qui s'effondre oui
et pour meubler il m'appelle d'urgence
je vais chercher ma guitare au lycée et
j'ai meublé j'ai chanté des chansons je
dois dire que j'ai pas eu tellement de
succès mais ça m'a donné le goût des
planches et c'est comme ça que je suis
devenu chanteur mais c'est vrai qu'il
faisait le mur à fontainebleau pour
aller jouer dans des cabarets convoi
venait de voir
il faisait semblant ne pas reconnaître
non non c'est pas ça c'est que j'avais
trouvé une astuce je chantais masqué sur
une gondole la scène c'était une gondole
et je disais que j'étais un chanteur de
venise enrico je m'appelais
et sa guitare oui c'est bien mais
personne ne me reconnaissez les premiers
fleurs c'est avec suzy ah bon avec suzy
puis par la suite on a eu d'autres
expériences quand même oui j'espère
justement la première fois que j'ai fait
d'amour c'était avec suzy non c'est avec
qui tu t'en souviens
oui c'était une je me rappelle c'est un
fontainebleau et c'était vraiment la
madone de tout le lycée je crois que
tous les lycées y est passé ça nous
ferait même année
et en plus c'était facile elle était
nettement plus vieille que nous c'était
notre madone ta première cuite tu t'en
souviens
oui c'était aussi aux 17 forte valeur
n'était pas venu pour rien ton 1er juin
j'ai fumé un joint une fois dans ma vie
c'est au canada j'étais avec avec plein
de copains et puis un jour je me suis
trouvé seul dans la chambre et le mon
copain devait donner un joint mais pour
fumer avec 30 personnes moi j'ai fumé
pour moi je vous raconte pas dans quel
état j'étais ça m'a dégoûté pour que la
venue compliquer la vie et le premier
disque était acheté le premier disque
que j'ai acheté c'est celui de mon beau
père parce qu'il faut que je vous dise
que
mon père et mon beau père avait un
magasin de disques où il pouvait être
très très très riche en vendant les
disques de tout le monde mais il vendit
que les disques de leur orchestre
et donc les premiers disent que j'ai eu
c'est et ceux de mon beau-père première
fois à valentina alors vous faites le
sampler à ma place pythagore
alors c'est la première fois qu'on se
voit on va faire une interview première
fois vous vous souvenez de votre premier
noël
non bonsoir annoncé est-ce que vous
soulevez de votre première objet fétiche
non salut bande de la caisse que
ponctionner de votre premier péché ah ça
oui c'était quoi
la gourmandise est l'argent
jamais jamais c'était bien été le
premier amour c'était tout de suite bien
oui c'était donc j'ai pas besoin de vous
demander le premier flirt le premier
baiser le premier homme parce que dès le
premier amour c'était réglé
hawaï a pris un mot c'était ben oui oui
vous en garder un bon souvenir à très
bon ça m'a aidé pour après elle est sexy
c'est devant tina vous dit de moi comme
ça
serge on peut pas mosaïque et thierry
loin vous êtes sûr
thierry aux aguerris mais c'est déjà
leaké
[Applaudissements]
prime aux héritiers de chercher à
échapper à losail
mais comme ça qu'ils devaient comme ça
comment ça va je t'embrasse et oui
plaisir avec plaisir le plaisir qu'ils
soient là moi je dis qu'on est beaucoup
mieux ici
non mesdames messieurs ce qu'il ya de
l'air qui servent à la casse et donc
armer bien là
[Musique]
on bouge pas tant maintenant à voir
comment c'est normal refaire on rallume
quand j'en ai vu qu ont bougé est-ce
qu'on peut rallumer
voilà la tension dans le gym gueule on
ne bouge pas alors attention un peu 3
[Musique]
mon premier souvenir
un souvenir avec mon grand père je dois
avoir 3 ans et demi et je suis cachée
sous une table ronde où il ya un trou et
je pique du saucisson c'est rigolo
le petit chat et la symbolique c'est
rigolo on s le père de jane votre
premier choc dans la vie votre premier
choc brutal mais revers
je dirais sûrement la mort du grand-père
way qui est intervenu très peu de temps
ça a été accepté la mort la mort de mon
grand père qui était un journal
différent c'est sa première baffe mes
parents m ont jamais mis paf j'ai juste
ma mère qui m'a mis un brin dans la
gueule on perd mais c'était en fait on
joue à mike tyson sur l'île j'en ai
décroché il s'est calmé de seconder et
la regarder par terre et j'ai senti que
ça n'allait pas trop bien et je lui dis
pardon pas prenez s'est retourné c'est
sympa si les douaniers ont jamais le
dire pardon papounet ses compagnons du
doigt votre premier objet fétiche
message j'avais un singe en dressage non
un format maman à l'aplomb et un singe
en peluche et évidemment quand je suis
né m'a donné un singe et moi j'avais un
saint loup je lui ai arraché l'oeil
quand j'étais tout petit et je la peña
carnet extrême un saint jacques
c'est le premier péché je crois que
c'est quand j'ai lu ouais un jour j'ai
piqué sont mal à ma mère quand j'étais
tout petit pour aller acheter qd un
bonbon avec une copine je crois c'est
une première communion dans les rues oui
j'ai fait vous aussi ça sic et d'argent
jamais appelée maman avec nous
le premier amour nasa va c'est le fisc
la meilleure mine mana qui s'appelait
harry dont je connais comme est amoureux
tout petit assises ont été consentis sur
la plage et il m'a dit d'ailleurs si moi
ce que je trouve assez drôle que je
faisais du chanteur toute la journée où
je me cachais avec lui et simon brassait
pas je vous jure les jeux met à hurler
plus personne faut une quinzaine de
membres à savoir si votre première cuite
très grand ennemi 14 ans 13 ans et demi
j'habitais dans les caraïbes
quand j'ai présenté donc raison donc
kamikaze puisque c'est que je me
rappelle plus que c'est la fin ça c'est
la tradition gainsbourg les cocktails le
kamikaze votre 1er juin
la même époque si l'on veut bien ce
voyage à saint barthélemy assez chouette
savard est votre premier avec star va
c'est chouette ça dépend de la de la
terre dirigerait je crois que j'aurais
jamais pris sauf peut-être une fois on a
filé dans un verre parce que je crois
que j'étais plus excité que je joue et
que j'aurais été en buvant un verre quoi
je cours est un peu dans tous les sens
donc là j'écris je crois font de mika
clos dans le vert -à vous pensez vous
avez pris avec star à votre insu de ce
qu'on a mis dans notre aide se séparent
mais je sais juste que j'ai couru dans
tous les sens qu'on insiste sur la
grille deux étapes du tour de france
voilà c'était la première fois la preuve
l'interview première fois et tout le
monde vous a trouvé formidable on ne
bouge pas
elle a bougé vous avez bougé là on
recommence en rade et attention je vais
vous faire une interview première fois
je
[Musique]
elle peut pas s'empêcher vous n'êtes pas
quand approche m'ont inscrit à vous êtes
t'offre à quand bien premiers souvenirs
nos jours j'ai rencontré jean françois
lamour guadeloupe
il est venu en plus en guadeloupe après
la télé vous l'avez vu à la télé il est
venu vraiment aussi j'ai rencontré
l'amour c'est le jour il m'a signé le
premier autographe
ouais ça c'est grand souvenir c'est vrai
a décidé de votre premier péché dit la
vérité ici on dit la vérité c'est pas
comme d'habitude de la télé ici on dit
la vérité
j'ai écouté les bonbons de mon frère et
j'avais juré que c'était pas moi non je
m'attendais à un prix beaucoup plus hard
à ses premiers essais le premier bon
deuxième à la première idole jean
françois lamour ont fait dire oui
c'était pas de mots non c'était carl
lewis à carl lewis premier amour mauvais
souvenirs à vent mauvais souvenir non
c'est un escrimeur à c'était un
escrimeur et je reste encore dans les
crimes normalement tu devrais dire il
tirait mal je sais pas ce que tu fous
merde moi bon premier flirt et irait mal
c'est le même ouais premier rhum premier
amour premiers flirts premier homme
c'est le même escrimeurs zéro pointé
c'est ça oui ça plaît ah oui et c'est
tant mieux
moi c'est de ma faute votre première
cuite
je l'attends toujours genre heureusement
peur du lendemain quand je ramène plutôt
que 20 morts le 1er juin
pas encore vous avez tout à découvrir
attendait mais se formèrent décalage
petit en twittant oui premier dopage et
j'envisage pas ah bon vous droguez pas
vous non pour le moment je ferais
comment jouer sur mon bras comme un
poète champion du monde sans vous donner
mon sang entraînant et en croyant en
étant entouré par une bonne
par de bonnes personnes rien que ça
c'est beau surtout c'est que je suis
passionné donc oui ça sape l'audi sa
championne du monde aura lui même
bien connu c'est la première fois qu'on
se voie je vous faire une interview
première fois
[Applaudissements]
voilà j'ai treize jours car alors
fabrice votre premier souvenir
mon premier souvenir pour les souvenirs
de votre ville voilà la question
moi je les comprends je vais répondre
[Applaudissements]
on a fait venir c'est mon premier jour
d'école justement acheter ma mère avait
gardé longtemps les jours d'école avait
était rien vous avez quitté votre maman
c'est ça le petit garçon quand excusé
pour sa maman bah oui moi aussi j'ai un
fils une journée scolaire à l'école
votre première baffe donc vous avez
reçue à peut-être le même jour à le
faire je le vends un coup de poing vous
avez donné donné aux basses et je pense
que tout le monde à l'école mais bon à
10 ans j'ai commencé la boxe
maintenant c'était vrai à 12 ans non
mais d'accord donc la seule vraiment
j'avais le droit
votre premier péché ont dépêché les
premiers j'en suis à pitre au noble art
il attend cet argent comme tout le monde
par un sommet avec les filles 14 ans non
mais bon vous savez c'est la passion de
la vie bon écoute poule ses péchés ou
pas les poules et les lapins
le tome i idol premier rideau hall aux
battues je pense que quand j'ai commencé
la boxe moi je me dirais même un boxeur
que j'aimais bien donc je crois si vous
le connaissez mais j'étais de marvin
hagler wenger ou balade entre un boxeur
du boxeur rasé voilà maintenant quand
même
aussi on s'intéresse un peu à la boxe on
reconnaît marie c log avait dit je
voudrais est si célèbre qu'elle foncé
halimi qu'on parle de moi comme d'un
alphonse halimi
non je vous les gens passionnés style
rambo crown un problème toujours en
habitant l'an 2000 et en parle toujours
des anciens boxeurs et ça c'est bon ils
ont fait quelque chose que j'aime bien
tout ça mais maintenant je dire faut
qu'ils faut qu'on arrête de parler
autant 227 et donc c'est ce que je dis
maintenant c'est oublié vous je veux
laisser une trace dans la boxe comme le
cerveau ou à l'ennemi ouais ils ont fait
c'est vrai vous avez raison c'est vrai
qu'il ya 30 40 50 ans les boxeurs cerdan
c'est une énorme star quoi et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes double champion
du monde est connue bien sûr votre nom
est connu mais vous était pas aussi tard
que ça ouais ouais voilà donc mais avec
une catégorie mais disons que c'est un
boxeur d'avant le boxon d'avant ne
pourrait pas gagner maintenant j'ai
dansé des comparaisons qui sont qui sont
pas possibles
c'est une histoire
fall et la méditation premier amour non
souvenirs amour à 14 ans j'ai rencontré
ma femme de maintenant vous avez vous
pris
je vous demande pas votre première
expérience sexuelle c'est complètement
ça c'est fou ces tromperies entre tanger
et la rive l'autre
bah oui ça fait ses classes est possible
c'est possible vous êtes un cas spécial
dont le jargon du ciel et ses hommes et
une femme dans une vie ça va c'est
extraordinaire dans ce scénario mes
parents mais j'avais 18 ans votre
première cuite s'en souvenait oui à 11
ans j'ai fait exprès pour dire voilà
bonjour j'ai pris une cuite et vous en
avez pris d'autres après quand même
quelques quelques unes le 1er juin
vers 15 ou 16 ans vous a pas bronché
j'ai déjà reçu plusieurs fois mais c'est
par exemple est votre premier de dopage
à l'eau joie
presque pas les boxers moi c'est
toujours ce que je réponds je dis donc
si il y en a peut-être d'un cépage le
dos mais il n'y a pas une piqûre on est
un médicament qui peut faire qu'on ait
un viseur qu'on sache où mettre le coup
et où il n'ya pas de piqûre aux
médicaments pareil qui font qu'ils
écoutent plus une option c'est pas
possible
voilà donc si vous avez un merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
changez de l'exemple oui j'ai mal agi
mais je comprends pas bien intérêt ouais
c'est vrai ça remarque que je
l'imaginais vous avez des petits moyens
mais déjà je sais elle vote newton à ses
premiers souvenirs premier souvenir est
votre premier souvenir de votre vie
c'est dur ça j'en ai vu des jeunes
joueurs ne se met pas donc c'est ça
c'est ça en prenant la souris sexuelle
ah bon vous assez ça vous allez trouver
un joueur vous êtes là mounawah mais
c'était vous souvenez c'est pas très
vite dans une cage d'escalier ascenseurs
les ascenseurs canton et quand on ne
fait pas exprès je veux dire c'est
beaucoup moins drôle
c'est vrai votre premier objet fétiche
je peux pas le dire dans l'ascenseur
aussi vraiment ouais le premier péché le
vol le vol
ouais vous souvenez ce que c'était c'est
le porte-monnaie de votre mère au début
non non il a piqué un ballon et personne
l'a rattrapé le marquage ce et ses
petites voitures le gr 1 qui de voitures
dans des boutiques web votre premier
jour à l'école vous en souvenez
très difficile ouais et le premier jour
au stade français je me suis demandé ce
que je fais là j'ai eu beaucoup de
nouvelles têtes renouvelle entraîneur
nouvelle présidente je me suis dit j'ai
peut-être pas fils le meilleur choix
le premier rideau hall enrico c'était
qui ma première idéale vaut maintenant
on à madonna a dit dont madonna votre
mari vous en a voulu
ah oui l'histoire de madonna s'est pas
l'histoire quand il prit madonna justify
my love c'était votre la rhétorique
c'est une chanson très non mais à la fin
vous savez ce qu'elle a dit non ce qu'on
peut dire c'est la telline française
peut tout dire dans cette émission on
peut tout dire à la fal diffa que oui
oui l'ex mari était en train de prier
alors il se lève il prend le cv il le
jette par la fenêtre en disant je ne
veux plus jamais entendre parler de
cette femme chez moi à will haven rico
qui passe en twingo s'était évité
l'accident de et j'ai évacué évacue
premier flirt
ça vous a pas laissé un souvenir
impérissable
premièrement je voulais lui parler
oui je me souviens la première fois avec
une fille vous en souvenez là oui bon
d'accord et avec un garçon c'est la
grande très très mal passé je fais mal
passée très près vous avez pu
recommencer donc il résilie une fois
quand même c'est bien il faut essayer
devrait s'appeler sapé par maman je
plaisantais
il est jamais essayé il va t'amener
cette botte qu'innovateur non mais vous
n'avez jamais eu envie d'essayer non non
c'est marrant ça comme ça ici et ouais
c'est bien passé non mais j'ai essayé
d'accord et la première fois à plusieurs
vous en souvenez oui et alors
sympathique du sol en même temps les usa
saluent la balle des trucs sympas la lie
à lutter debout son visage s'est
illuminé mais combien de filles comme
garçons trois garçons deux filles
espagne ah ouais bah voilà canal c'est
tous les jours non sorbonne où un canal
quand on fréquente l 1221 première cuite
douloureuse douloureuse pastis oui nivet
pastis et un an
du rose et du pastis pays connaissent un
haricot à saint tropez l'été regarde le
1er juin
mardi 9h30 17 ans je vous ai laissé un
souvenir impérissable
c'est très mauvais ah ben ouais vous ai
plus jamais recommencer
non il a marqué contre son cerveau est
international de rugby certainement je
me disais aussi première ecstasy jamais
pour ça que vous êtes international
diori les six premiers millions pas
encore pas encore
[Applaudissements]
non
dîner bah oui mais moi j'aime aux normes
à manger quand vous avez été très
sympathique que je voulais je vais faire
un petit cadeau
ouais c'est le nouvel hymne du stade
français ah oui life is strange son
avance et il saura que c'est vous qui
avez passé le stade français c'est
qu'ils avaient relancé à will survive et
ça c'est un original sa wii va très bien
merci beaucoup je l'écouterai en pensant
à vous merci que l'esclave 2010 y arrive
poussée et mais attend le match
[Musique]
monsieur spock portait première baffe
preuve jeunes près je ne sais pas
c'était une baffe ou une droite si
c'était une base c'était peut-être vos
parents c'était une droite s'était pas
vos parents ou mon frère ou un autre
frère premiers désirs première fois que
j'avais éprouver du désir pour quelqu'un
ou non une paire de baskets sûrement oui
premier amour mais je le cherche encore
à quai ici alors on a fait ce qu'il faut
ce soir quand même bien le folie car on
veut quand même là on peut guère faire
plus mais aussi monsieur kenya qui
espère bien il faut aller habiter dans
le larzac en même temps un premier
organe michel encore la paire de baskets
et la paire de boeufs premiers tags vous
étiez tagueurs avant
ouais avant de faire la rue blanche très
très tôt ouais regard que l'âge je sais
pas 14 en août à guy quoi c'est très
compliqué mais en tag est beaucoup mais
vous savez si bien dire chaussée des
dessins s'était déjà commencé par le tag
pur et dur et puis après c'est parti
vers la peinture plus plu soit les
fresques et c est ce qu on appellera
vous graphite et pur et dur maintenant
premier cachet d'aspirine les bonnes
réponses
premier voyage maroc voir la famille
quand on était petit première cuite
tarifs et retards motivés de l'alcool
vous pas vraiment lent je bois du vin
est ce que vous êtes un musulman est ce
que vous êtes musulman pratiquant
musulman mais aussi parce qu'on a eues
ici djamel bouras ont été très étonné
parce que là aussi c'est un truc était
très souvent été très étonné c'est un
musulman qui revendiquait sa religion ma
jeune moderne tout qui revendiquait sa
religion la télévision et on s'est
aperçu en écoutant djamel bouras que
finalement c'était très rare aussi ça
faisait des cathos qui viennent des
juifs qui viennent parler de la religion
mais musulmans nés
on était très étonnée vous vous êtes
musulman pratiquant vêtements nous y
sommes en pratiquant de père de mère et
de traditions et vous faites comme nous
avec le préservatif si vous buvez un
petit couteau 1er juin n'ont pas
toujours pas de juin non à part les
vacances fin juin premières lignes rer b
hall de la gare du nord on rallume serge
de maternité route première fois en
baisse la lumière ne bouge pas project
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
leur ballade you man on a ledge elle
était un facile c'est pas bouger il faut
recommencer recommence on rallume la
lumière à cause des doigts à la présence
et pas à cause des douars c'est à cause
des manuels attention un deux trois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
réussi celui-là edwards a été un pas
qu'on me dit dans l'oreillette que
c'était un pic s'est pas mouillé vous
non plus non alors emmanuel comme c'est
la première fois qu'on se voit on va
faire une première fois c'est encore un
mois oui premier souvenir
votre premier souvenir quand j'ai
embrassé un garçon derrière le
préfabriqué à couvrir j'avais trois ans
très précoce à la deuxième question
c'était premiers désirs mais j'ose pas
vous la poser parce que c'était là
c'était le même
c'était le premier rendez vous amoureux
c'est encore le meriva oui je me sens
mieux pêcher c'était le même j'avais 12
ans en empêcher
n'essayez pas de détourner la question
emmanuel premier match avoue que c'était
le même à dix c'était dans une église au
gendre à ses rejets mais avec la longue
avec la nature comique ou de foot
c'était roger première passion c'était
roger médisance et rouge est quand même
il a du pauvre et premier réveil à deux
ce n'est pas roger quand même
réveil à deux premières fois vous êtes
réveillé à 2% dans un lit eh bien
c'était au pensionnat de maisons
laffitte et je me suis endormi et voilà
c'était je me suis poli
c'était je ne s'est réveillé dans
l'internât des garçons
si vous êtes très bien premier week-end
à 2 alors que les autres c'était la
première premier week end à deux c'était
avec roger
et oui oui de partir en angleterre oui
c'est que ça dure et vachement corps et
causé un premier chagrin d'amour
interrogé ridoret
non non c'est que pour vous mais rejet
là il veut expliquer que c'est pas lui
non mais bien sûr malgré un levier ce
qu'il écrit fait malgré ce qu'il écrit
il faut voir ce qui les arrange et roger
ce formidable jeu après jc medouar en
plus de gens y en a mais c'est ailleurs
les a réunis ce soir
voilà complet d'abord roger ensuite les
douars très bien donc première vague
foot tout ça c'est du roger chagrin
d'amour c'est roger aussi je sais pas
j'en avais tout le temps à ouais j'avais
un nez en trompette des taches de
rousseur et ils m'ont tous abandonné
donc j'ai juste dit tout haut les mecs
tout le dos à gré d'un bureau permanent
première rupture avec quatre ont quatre
ans c'est jeune je venais de me marier
ouais d'avoir un arbre ah oui ouais on
lui dit j'aurais aimé vous connaître
j'ai divorcé après midi vingt ans c'est
toujours pareil quoi sert des ménages ça
qu'on fait entre trois et quatre ans
emmanuelle béart a vécu tout ce que nous
on a mis 40 ou 50 ans aviv quoi première
envie de vous suicider première envie de
me suicider j'avais six mois moi je me
rappelle pas vous avez envie quand même
ben oui messieurs comme tout le monde
j'imagine
j'ai pas envie de me suicider vous étés
pluvieux j'avais 32 ans
et qu'est ce qui vous était arrivé
chagrin d'amour c'est classique avant au
nom auquel sentimentale
bon et noir j'ai subsides vous posez la
question à vous aussi est ce que vous
avez envie de vous suicider une fois
dans votre beau tout le monde on a envie
j'irai comme un manuel beurre laveran 15
comme ça n'était pas assez important
pour ça c'est bien bonne réponse on
allume la lumière comme c'est votre
premier roman va faire une interview
première fois bouge pas
ça va bouger vous allez punis est ce
qu'on peut apporter le martinet qu'on a
acheté à pigalle la finition c'est une
interview première fois moins que lors
de l'édition sa nouvelle fois vous allez
répondre franchement j'avais essayé
premiers désirs littéraire j'ai dit
franchement oui mais pas ça peut
traduire par les livres oui c'est vrai
petit baiser premier baiser c'est une
chanson un peu guimauve dont je me
souviens plus là mais je connais la
chanson en revanche je n'ai plus de
votre premier baiser cité sport
pensionnat avec une copine jennifer
jennifer on ne monte pas thierry je
connais bien
il a été élevé chez les curés alors il
sait comment ça va s'arrêter là mais moi
j'aime embrasser la vérité là c'est long
très tard en fait elle est à vous donner
de la première fois oui bien sûr et
alors très bien il s'appelait pas eu
l'oeil et le bon dieu ni le gifle et
première à noah sort gagnant il m'avait
une première passion la littérature
non mais c'est vrai parce que c'est vrai
que le livre madame soleil m'a sauvé de
beaucoup de choses et m'a aidé à me
construire première nuit à deux avec
vous après après l'émission et 4 senna
partout - est-ce que vous vous souvenez
de votre première nuit à 2 1 + 1
c'est ça non non non de martine eu des
larmes pour un garçon j'ai pas pu ré un
bon c'est ça les asiatiques première
rupture afin de deux ans c'était dur
c'est toujours dire vous êtes remis ça
votre première vraie transgression
sexuelle à trois ans 1re div
c'est sa première fois à plusieurs je ne
dis rien je ne veux pas que ça se sache
c'est peut-être c'est peut-être là en ce
moment un peu ce que je livre beaucoup
je me déshabille et un première fois
avec une fille jamais bonjour vous êtes
un écrivain est par essence mans ouais
c'est chose on m'avait dit on m'avait
lycée finale sont difficiles je vous
fais un interview première fois on ne
bouge pas pendant le génial
[Applaudissements]
bon état ou première fois c'est facile à
dire là bas c'est la première fois la
wii c'est en fait la première fois votre
premier souvenir
mon premier souvenir de quoi de votre
vie la mienne dit d'armand oui
effectivement votre premier souvenir
vous étiez tout petit petit petit petit
je me souviens que j'étais amoureuse
d'un garçon en maternelle qui
ressemblait beaucoup au prince dont et
amos candidats et le dessin animé et moi
j'étais amoureuse du prince donnerais tu
es amoureux ce qu'en dit parce que
j'étais un peu comme candy est donc ce
petit garçon la maternelle qui était
réelle ressemble beaucoup à ce garçon
que ça plus antonio être comme ça et
donc j'étais absolument amoureuse lui
c'était fou mais j'avais meilleur ami
qui est amoureuse lui aussi est donc on
lui courait après toutes les deux comme
des hystériques d'amour de maternelle et
on lui montrait un petite culotte sa as
ça commence fort votre premier péché
péché oui j'avais nyala pas péché mortel
mon premier péché
le premier est de l'avis de gérard de la
sienne de la vie de sophie premier péché
mon premier péché mais j'ai pas vous le
dire
voici maintenant c'est un truc ouais
hein tout seul donc c'est bon on a
compris votre premier amour donc si
j'avais dit c'était le petit anthony la
lafa ce qui ressemblait au prince quoi
si on appelle ça un amour ouais mais
après il ya votre premier amour amour
quoi ouais c'était qui le nom le prénom
et nom qui s'était même je vous dit pas
le nom et le prénom c'est un mec
ouais ça se mêlent 30 lyon dès
l'accouchement va être un peu difficile
mais on va y arriver
non mais bon un mec d'accord mais à part
ça quoi c'est quel âge vous aviez 15 ans
à 15 ans de premier amour c'était 15 ans
pourquoi c'est trop tard moi je trouve
ça un peu tard mais quand à 16 ans moi
j'attends d'une vraie histoire je parle
pas des petites ses amourettes oui
d'accord d'accord
bon disons 6 à 15 ans que tout ça s'est
passé quoi ah ouais bah voilà première
fois à trois 3 ans à 3 jeudi
quand on était à 2 c 15 ans on passe à
15 ans la vie d'un seul coup d'un seul
coup on va passer à 15 ans et demi avec
vous gérez à part dans la première fois
partie des camps dans les années 70 j'ai
même moi j'aimerais qu'on passe
interview l'addition est sûrement là
elles sont là bien
tiens donc on a traversé les années
soixante dix première fois trois bonnes
heures par quatre
voilà c'est à peu près le même parcours
que le vôtre mais pour la première fois
à capcom premier chagrin d'amour donc
oui donc c'est celui où les gâteaux baby
sitter voile à dakar j'ai compris le 10
kg d'accord ok j'ai compris première
tentative de suicide
[ __ ] la sagem agir pourquoi vous ai
jamais ici de vous suicider non jamais
ça veut dire que le nutella satuc en bon
madame de fontenay natation va catherine
ne serait bien qu'on revient vite mais
ça fait longtemps voilà c'est quand tu
veux me dit catherine dans l'oreillette
merci qu'elle avait une autre de
gendarmes pour noël qui touche alors bon
premier première cuite
je sais pas vers 16 17
c'est avec le premier l'a tout chercher
ensemble bien mon bonbon non pas le
match quand tu es demandé sa première
cuite il m'a dit je m'en souviens pas
j'ai dit pourquoi il va livrer j'étais
bourré
premier pétard c'était un bon c'était la
bonne époque j'étais là effet les vaut
connaître en fait première ligne jamais
très bien c'est bien vous avez raison
première chose que vous faites le matin
en vous réveillant à pisser je veux
c'est que je me rappelais pas du tout
votre dernière volonté si vous deviez
mourir pisser
au regard des dernières volontés si vous
deviez mourir passer une soirée gerrard
rio
tout le monde bouge quand le jingle
importe votre premier souvenir vous
souvenez votre premier souvenir à
longjumeau risque quand j'étais déguisé
en fait à l'école votre premier choc
mon premier choc tu t'es vue on fait
quand t'es quoi tu t'es vu en fait
peut-être quand on m'a transformé quand
j'ai transformé quelqu'un avec la
baguette
pascal parce que schilling s'ouvrit
match les lyonnais il ya un petit délai
il ya un petit délit chacun quand tu dis
quelque chose de temps qu'on traduise et
où qu'elles soient retardement si je me
la faire et du die welt il y ait des
business qui vient de meilleur allié
qu'est-ce qui viennent
votre premier péché ça vous vous en
souvenez vous est-ce que c'était un
péché j'ai coupé les cheveux d'une fille
enfin c'est passé pas empêcher ça c'est
vous la trouviez trop joli ça s'apprend
parce qu'elle allait appliquer un mec
alors oui non simple jeu c'est un fait
ça c'est un peu je suis carrément un
péché s'est pressée cheveux dites moi
votre votre votre premier amour
oui belle sandrine ça lui rappelle cette
chanson ça ça vous rappelle vos premiers
errements et là elle a du mal à la main
ça l'air de rien elle sourit il est
tombé pour sa ligne c'est quelque chose
de très très dur de crêpes
elle peut plus écouté cette chanson très
très fort elle sourit parce qu'elle est
forte
c'est vous qui l'avait larguée oui parce
qu'il van hamme largo si on est tombé
sur un os un point c'est l'art dosettes
d'europe centrale toutes les deux d'un
point commun elles s'appellent hernych
ait dit oui c'est vrai alain ces deux
points communs vous êtes d'europe
centrale toutes les deux vous êtes des
pays en fait de décommander mon premier
livre d'une part les gibiers silvana non
non non et
[Musique]
chez lui qui parle à jean tu peux lui
demander hier mais jamais soif c'est sa
banane et madame tenez
aux premières cuites
oui un réveillon de nouvel an il ya
longtemps longtemps
ouais avec ma soeur premier pétard
jamais non pas une taffe oui comme
clinton et ça m'a fait passer la fumée
voilà votre première chance dans la vie
qui vous la donner je pense que sans mes
parents
premier échec c'est quoi mon premier
chèque
je sais à peu
je peux t'aider mois moi je veux pas
très sympa mais je te regarde à la télé
non je dirais l'irrésolu parce que c'est
vraiment un film que j'aime pas ah ouais
et la première chose que vous faites le
matin vous réveillant je vais voir ma
fille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais vic n'a pas bougé par ledit n'ai
jamais dit ça il est vous êtes bien
quand même
pourtant il est rapide quant à julie
elle peut pas s'empêcher de bouger bien
alors comme il est souligné souvenirs à
part le normand je crois oui c'est la
première fois que j'ai vu de la neige
j'étais tout petit et samassa m'a choqué
et ce qui m'a le plus marqué c'est que
j'ai dit à ma mère regarde maman il
pleut de la purée hélas non c'est vrai
c'est la manière a dit ce nuage qui va
être très con
premier choc abreu me choque c'est quand
comme mon père m'a appris que les
village people était homosexuel ouais
moi c'est quand les beatles se sont
séparés il est homosexuel
non mais cette sonate de yoko ono j'en
veux premier mensonge
premier mensonge e journée j'en ai
beaucoup des mensonges ça fait plaisir
j'ai fait un grand compliment au moins
pour les choses avec philosophie
ça c'est en dernier mensonge premier
baiser avec la langue
bah premier baiser c'est une fille qui
s'appelait nique puis elle tourner la
langue trop vite oui et en plus elle
ouvrait pour la bouche ça servirait
première fois première fois à 2 dans un
camping avec une belle première fois à
troyes jamais hélas nier les allemands
nos copines de montbéliard attendait
france 2
c'est ma classe regardez votre caméra et
lancé un appel tout de suite c'est à ça
que ça sert la télé je recherche une
nounou nord 2-1 deux nounous non une
j'en ai déjà une wii j'ai déjà ma nounou
une deuxième nous nous tout est accepté
ouais y avez-vous pensé parce qu'un
parti ramos avaient entassé l'annoncé là
vous êtes vraiment un mec c'est à dire
que quand vous pensez à faire l'amour à
trois vous pensez tout de suite que la
personne supplémentaire sera une fille
et pas un garçon très sympa pour votre
fiancée ouais mais nancy on faisait
l'amour à trois avec un mec moi j'aurais
vraiment l'impression de faire l'amour
avec le mec et j'ai pas envie de voir
son machin qui ballotte ça m'intéresse
maintenant tu seras le dos du gardien
caennais c'est marrant les mecs vous
êtes tous les mains première rupture
première fois se rapprocher rupture
ça s'était très vite c'était une copine
qui est venu fera voisine qui est venu
frapper à ma part j'avais 12 ans elle
m'a dit ouais il ya béatrice qui
voudrait sortir avec toi j'ai dit
attends faut que je réfléchisse je suis
partie au judo de trois heures je suis
revenue la même voisine venue frapper
alors moi j'étais prêt à donner ma
réponse à mes ouailles à béatrice
qu'elle changeait d'avis à 100 avec
christophe et ses premières ruptures gd
s'est rien passé dans ça s'est bien
passé ta rentrée d'été ceinture bleue
quand marie mes premiers vrais chagrin
d'amour
quand j'ai quitté ma mère pour monter à
paris
que c'est beau ça voulait quand j'ai
quitté ma première tentative de suicide
jamais mais jamais eu envie de vous
suicider voir plutôt mourir
non mais après les pétards je ne veux
pas de nom bon été non non non non j'ai
déjà tiré une ou deux taffes
mais je suis pas non c'est pas mon oui
bon oui j'en ai fumé
m
ayez déjà melnyk la première chose que
vous faites le matin au réveil eux
bagdad au réveil j'ai beaucoup de mecs
questionnaire sabour peut-être pas
répondu la même chose est ce que je vais
dire là par contre l'école le matin
non non non le matin les matins je
devrais bientôt le matin non je sais
qu'il fut un gros pas de l'homme attend
le matin et là il ya des mecs qui vont
se reconnaître moi j'ai la petite
érections matinales
ouais alors alors je laisse pas passer
ça et je fais l'amour même si je suis
tout seul
eh bien on veut allumer un ne bouge pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]